[Music]
all right i got a great story about him
cool him yeah okay
this is an advanced copy right
all right here we go episode number 143
with the one and only dave rubin in the
house dave how you doing i'm doing well
i feel like we did a show already in the
five minutes that i've been sitting here
so we did about a three hour show that's
right so we are ready this morning yes
we talked about a lot of things excited
to be
uh uh well i think you can't yet read
the book but you can order the book
right now his book's coming out don't
uh burn this country the last book he
wrote don't birth this book was a new
york times seller
uh dave you probably do want the best
shows
on youtube with the reuben report your
interview style you bring everybody from
both sides and i think you're very very
another one of those voices that's very
necessary today well i appreciate that
and i can throw that compliment right
back at you i've seen some of your
interviews where you're talking with
people that you obviously disagree with
and by the way that shouldn't be that
revolutionary right it shouldn't be i
will be totally honest i mean it's
gotten harder to do over the years so if
you watch the trajectory of my show over
say the seven years that i've been doing
interviews
it's gotten more difficult to talk to
lefties because something happened to
the left the the old school liberals
sort of the bill maher liberals there
aren't as many of them anymore they're
willing to agree to disagree and hey
let's let's go our separate ways after
talking about some stuff we don't have
to destroy each other
that's gotten much harder with the
modern progressive so i try still to
reach out when i can uh but i'm also
interested in building things and i'm
not so interested in just talking about
the stuff anymore so i've i've shifted
more into the to the business side of
all of this
so i'll talk to these people but but it
has gotten more difficult and i'm truly
i'm not as interested as i used to be
really yeah really yeah i'm not so why
is that is it because you don't think
change can happen or is it just because
no because you already feel like you've
had all the conversations i feel in some
ways well you know this as an
interviewer you can talk about things a
certain amount of times and then you
have to start doing some things too so
that's where i started a tech company in
the middle of this because i was
concerned about all the free speech
stuff related to big tech and all that
but it was also that you know the woke
ideology has become
so entrenched and deep and cult-like i
would say that i'm actually not that
interested anymore in
trying to convince those people that
they're wrong over time i think as a lot
of them grow up and learn about reality
and have a little understanding of what
humanity is some of them will come along
but i'm more interested in strengthening
people that are doing good things it's
one of the reasons i love living in
florida now after three months it's like
we've got this guy desantis who look i
don't want a king but this is the guy
who's walking right through the fire
right now he you know we live in florida
this is the tip of the spear of freedom
it's like we got a chance to model this
thing across the country so i'm much
more interested in promoting good ideas
than just having the retread
conversations about why socialism is bad
or communism is better whatever not to
say those things aren't valuable and you
can wake up a certain amount of people
but i'd rather sort of blaze new trials
into hey there's better ideas out there
and go do something with your life dave
what was the tipping point for you to
leave california like if you were to say
well the tipping point was five years
ago but i finally made a decision today
or was it like covet i'm done i'm sick
of it let's start looking at different
places and then you looked at tennessee
texas and florida and you said i'm going
to go to florida yeah so
i moved to la in 2013. uh we had about a
thousand bucks
from new york from new york so i'm a
true new yorker born in brooklyn grew up
in long island i went to suny binghamton
i lived in manhattan most of my life so
really the only two places as an adult
that i've lived until these last three
months were new york city and la and yet
the ideas that i talk about are the
stuff that people care about in the
middle of the country so i don't know
what happened i don't know what happened
i had these two coasts and somehow my
ideas kind of kind of came to them when
you moved from new york to l.a did you
come with that new york you know coastal
ideology to oh yeah i was i was a lefty
i worked i worked for the young turks i
was a bernie supporter all of that all
that all that stuff it's all it's true
all of it as uh
solo said yeah it was all true um
but there were a couple moments i mean
look the the two years of covid
demolished los angeles los angeles is a
shell of itself hollywood has been
destroyed okay so i could do all the
basic stuff the crime the homelessness
is the drug
i'll tell you what the final moment was
the final straw and i had been thinking
about it for about a year
back and forth could i do it where was i
going to go nashville
dallas etc
i campaigned with larry elder for the
for the recall so i was opening on stage
with him and tor you know going out
there and meeting people and it was
amazing it was incredible you know they
called him the black face of white
supremacy that's what the l.a sometimes
article yeah yeah
young woman who threw an egg at him in
the gorilla mask that always i thought
somehow the media didn't pick that one
up you know it's like it was just
extraordinary anyway i'm out there with
this guy and there was such energy i met
so many good people they were not far
right they weren't even conservatives
most of them were liberals they were
california liberals who were mugged by
reality they were just good decent
people who suddenly their restaurants
were closed their kids were locked down
all of this stuff anyway the recall
obviously was a disaster
and three days after the recall you want
the exact moment your head is your mind
is going to explode three days after the
recall i got audited by the state
[Laughter]
that makes sense yeah and i said we have
you've never been audited before i've
never been audited before
my my stuff's all clean it's sure it's
all fine
uh we take very good care of all my
businesses um three days after got that
immediately
like literally i think i hung up the
phone and i called my real estate agent
i said get me out of here and we put the
we did that house privately
i sold it in three weeks basically and
then i had to really quickly figure out
i always felt that it was going to be
florida
uh but you know i love the the blaze
guys and i do some stuff with them and
glenn beck and glenn really wanted me in
dallas so i had a little moment of that
i love the daily wire guys and candace
and ben and so i did look at one house
in nashville but i am so happy to be
here and i'm i'm i'm really like as i
said i'm reborn here i feel you feel it
here in florida it's free and you're
saying you said something prior to
shooting you said i
love florida i don't know you could
curse if you want yeah there was an f in
there yeah no i i effing love florida
it's it's not just
it's not just the the politics of it
that that's good it's what it's doing to
the people
you know i don't know when the last time
you guys just went back to new york or
went to cali or just went to some of
these blue cities he's from cali yeah
yeah no i know so but i don't have you
been there just in the last couple
months like
i went to la
to shoot a prageru video about a month
ago i said to my guys i will fly in go
to the studio and get me the hell out of
there even though the prageru studio is
a half mile from my house i guess it
would have been nice to go look at it
again or something it was a disaster i
got asked for a vaccine passport to go
to coffee bean and tea leaf uh that
makes sense just everything about it
it's rotten and then even just the
greenery the greenery in florida is
beautiful and wonderful in the trees and
then you go to la and everything's dying
and dead and brown it's uh
what the hell am i being clear about
this yeah i'm very happy here and i
don't like that place by the way what
was the reason why you chose florida
over dallas and nashville you know it's
partly i think because of my well first
off i have some family here and we
hadn't had been in a state with family
for a long time most i'm from new york
as i said so most of my family's east
coast my folks have a place in florida
my sister lives in miami with her
husband and kids uh also because of the
tech side of things obviously miami is
just exploding right now in the tech
world so i wanted to be close to that
but at a political level you know for me
as someone that came from the left and
you know i have mostly libertarian views
but i don't mind con calling myself a
conservative now there's a wide thing
right right now happening on the right
you know you got the disaffected lefties
and the libertarians then you've got the
you know sort of evangelical or the
christian conservatives there really is
this movement of trying to figure out
can this thing really hold because there
are a lot of people that have different
beliefs serious beliefs that are very
different i felt the the stuff that i
care about the most it's working here in
florida meaning it's a little more of a
secular conservatism as opposed to you
go to nashville or you go to texas it's
a little more religious that's not
necessarily my thing i felt that the
ideas that i really care about can
flourish a little bit more here so it
was it was a series of things you know
the weather is good and all that stuff
tell him what the reasons you wanted to
go to florida he was from l.a he was in
dallas i mean he's got some very good
jobs listen i knew we were moving out of
la
in 2012 2013 when he moved to plano and
he moved to plano says
beautiful yeah so he says you got to
start looking into texas i'm also a
california refugee i came in 13 to texas
yeah and look at us
look at us now i came i came to florida
in 1980 guys so when he was
no but yeah but you know so at that time
i started looking at everything but
being middle eastern everybody it's
tough to leave your family
mom dad sister friends restaurants
things your cod went to glendale high
school so do i want to leave this you
know relationships i got and i started
looking i said nope i cannot build an
insurance company being headquartered
california no way in the world so i
looked at central for me it was
important to go to texas because i
travel a lot we have a couple hundred
150 offices nationwide so if i'm going
to la three hours three hours three
hours three hours florida would have
been six and back in the time difference
la would have been six and back and time
difference so dallas made the most most
sense because i was traveling a ton if
somebody's building a national business
i don't think florida or california
makes sense i think the best spot to be
in is a dallas is a houston is in austin
if you travel a ton and then so we moved
to houston we moved to dallas we lived
in plano for a few years
and then we were right by addison our
headquarters was in addison and then
gradually when covett hit i started
looking i said we gotta look at
tennessee
nashville i lived in tennessee for two
years when i was in the army and i said
why are they gonna stay here in dallas
but then i love the water i love the
water the ocean california i mean i just
love that right and i said listen if
california and texas had a baby it would
be florida so i said that was the best
combination to come to florida we've
been here now for what 14 months 13
months 14 months and i'm in love just as
much as you are i got to tell you so
people always say to me
is there anything you don't like i
honestly cannot think of anything yes i
could complain about the traffic a
little bit but i lived in new york and
la so no i'm not gonna is there anything
anything so okay let's let's do it let's
be so okay we haven't really experienced
a hurricane yet okay so i don't know
what a hurricane looks like i've been
through tornado i've been through wars
i've been through earthquakes yeah okay
we'll see what the hurricane gives you a
warning earthquake does not tornadoes
don't give you too much of a warning
hurricane you know for two or three days
that something's coming right plus it
was raining fire in l.a yeah come on
literally well dave
you moved here
iguanos are not vicious but
i want to revisit this exact
conversation in august in august and
september i get it my favorite is going
to be a little flatter i get a lot
better dave i get it okay so if there's
nine months out of the year this is the
best place to be in the world period
full stop yeah three months out of the
year
go anywhere else that's my opinion so
every summer i would travel i was here
for that it's hot as hell here that's
okay it did not bother me when i was
here well you're from around pat yeah
yeah
it's a good point right there oh you
know
i'm at a party with pat it was last year
at the bitcoin conference uh it was in
june last year it was hot out we were at
that party outdoors people are sweating
pat's wearing a jacket yeah yeah
i'm like this guy can
withstand anything it's chilly
yeah exactly yeah you want to take the
jacket off at i'm good yeah so if you
would sand the heat like with anything
they could take the heat forget about
the weather what was that conference
about that was about a mayor of a major
united states city coming out and in
favor of crypto and trying to attract uh
innovators and entrepreneurs to come to
us to come to a city shout out to so
forget about the exactly mayor suarez is
another reason that florida is so
wonderful i grew up here i had i had
about four years here in high school my
dad's job moved us here but i was born
and raised in california basically and
we were here there was a republican
governor his name was bob graham but if
you take a look at like a one to ten and
a tennis barry goldwater and a one is
bernie bob graham was like
exactly a five and he was trying to
build jobs he was trying to be not so
tourist and transitory you know the
snowbirds and so the seeds of this went
florida i think go back to 1980 and
there's guys like charlie crist and now
desantis that have been faithful to it
and they haven't screwed it up by trying
to go way one way or the other and i
think that's one of the benefits and
then suarez rises up fantastic hispanic
mayor representing every kid that can
wake up in miami in the morning and say
i could be mayor i could be mayor look
at that you know i was at an event uh
last night at keith roboy's house and
you know keith was the one that
originally sent the tweet that suarez
responded how can i help which basically
caused the influx i mean i would say par
part of the reason i'm here is because
of that so i was at this event at rabois
last night and suarez was there and he
gave a talk
and i'm standing there watching the guy
and i've met him a couple times i
interviewed him once and i'm thinking
man this is so the reverse 180 reverse
of what i was dealing with in l.a eric
eric garcetti was destroying actively
destroying and we can go okay were the
intentions good or not that that's an
interesting conversation i don't think
the intentions are good actually i think
they are intentionally doing this stuff
but i'm listening to suarez he's talking
about how they want to be this
international city that will be the hub
of crypto and the new economy and they
want to be 30 years ahead of america
when it comes to all of this other stuff
and because the federal government is so
screwy we just have to do what we think
is right and then last week i did a
prageru event where where desantis spoke
and all desantis says is basic honesty
it's not that he's out there saying the
most crazy stuff that's riling people up
in reality he's basically saying honest
decent stuff
which is revolutionary in 2022. and it's
just such a stark difference man from
from l.a and i know i'm preaching to the
choir yeah what was this event last
night at keith's house what was that he
just had like a little salon for bitcoin
conference so it was a lot of the the
tech bros and that was our good friend
jack abraham there i don't know
you know you know jack the pump
oh the pomp was there
the pomp shows up in shorts everyone
else everyone i'm feeling very i'm
feeling very underdressed today but
everyone else is decked out we had
dinner with pomp the other night he's
the only person in shorts i love pomp
he's a great guy jack because he can
yeah yeah adam's got a
anyways we were at this place
and it's 12 of us
a friend of mine ken golden the owner of
golden auctions who sold 41 million
dollars of cards collectible cards last
month is what he did yeah and they're
showing up are you telling me i
shouldn't have sold my baseball card no
you shouldn't you shouldn't 1987 to my
buddy evan for 400 bucks the whole thing
73 mvp i wonder what that's worth right
now well depends everything is about
grading right now but we're sitting
there having dinner and ken's trying to
get me to uh bid on these two pieces he
has one of them is a jackie robinson
game warrant jersey from the 30s for him
a million dollars and then he had a uh
he had a uh uh uh was it superman issue
number one yeah for 10 million and
that's 10 million as well issue number
one it was a great at eight and a half
but i did make a a few bids on what the
willie mays rookie the the leo messi
rookie and the 86 flea box that we had
on but anyways one guy's sitting here
we're having dinner and he says yeah i
have one of the holy grail cards okay
what do you have he says i have a honest
wagner sgc5 oh that's like it right
isn't that the card but an sgc5 i said
how much is an sgc5 it's about 25
million bucks okay cool so he's got a 25
million dollars gc5 uh in the corner
sgc3 honest wagner t206
everybody there had card collections
and then pom shows up and pom's not a
card guy yeah it's a bitcoin max
well maybe 90 percent he is right and he
starts and he shows him in his black
shorts black shirts
really cool cat but uh you're going to
see me those meetings will come and pop
in and pop out but we had your friend
here two weeks ago jank we had him on
yes my good buddy we had him on we're
like gilligan and the skipper yeah so
i like how you slow play when you
talk about him very slowly yes but we
but you you know you the reason why i
bring that up is the following yeah
here's why i bring it up so
the question i got joe and i were
talking uh uh rogan and i were talking
over the weekend over the week uh and
you know i i i look at
politics and i look at what's pulling
what more and who's winning okay
imagine the people on the right they're
like no you guys are going far too left
and the left is like no no you guys are
going far too right you got to come more
to the left right
okay so
jank goes from a say he's a republican
to an independent to a democrat to a
bernie
super love right that's what he goes i
have a very hard time
understanding that evolution that you go
that far left
as you age and his arguments are solid
arguments and some of the ones that he
makes for his side like okay fine that's
your argument i get it hey you know the
only mistake america made is when they
give 465 million dollars to elements
they should have bought a piece of the
company and had equity in it okay cool
so nationalized that's the argument
let's have more companies be owned by
the government and we regulate it and uh
they can't make more money i completely
disagree with the argument but i get
your point yeah but yeah his method of
making the argument i'll say okay yeah
i'll see how you're going to it but
who's winning today and there's a
question to everybody by the way tyler
think about this as well tomorrow i'm
coming to you as well you've been around
longer than we have who's winning today
is is the right pulling people more to
the right winning today is the center
holding this thing are they being tipped
to the left or tilted to the right or is
the left wing more trying to drag people
to their side
go on it you want to hit that one i want
you to go forward around longer no i'll
give yeah thank you very much for that i
appreciate that
um a little difference here you know age
before beauty is what he's trying to say
tom all right can i answer eventually
the um
so i look at a couple things and just
real real quick
i've been looking at um differentials in
voter registrations for the last
like three months
and there is
you're seeing it in college students
you're nodding you know some of the data
i'm talking about i definitely know this
version it's about five percent
ahead for um
you know independents and republicans
right now versus dems and even if you
take the independence out which you
would understand why a lot of people are
jumping to the middle like that you
still have republicans are ahead on
voter registrations right now going in
the midterm election so i think that is
a sign of what's kind of winning as the
new voters are registering let me add
one thing on that which is the florida
numbers and you guys can check me as i'm
saying it so i get the numbers roughly
right but uh i heard desantis say this
last week that florida basically before
him
had a two hundred thousand deficit on
the republican side in terms of
registered voters i think they're up
eighty thousand now that's two ways
yeah so that's that's a huge we can
check the exact numbers but that's a
huge huge shift right there that so
that's one thing i would also say that
the you know the left right thing
sort of doesn't make sense anymore
because trump came in and crushed the
system to a point that people who were
traditionally conservative started
sounding like liberals liberals started
especially now sound like the craziest
authoritarians so left right doesn't
make sense to me anymore in the in the
specific sense i usually try to say
you're either authoritarian or
libertarian and what i mean by that is
you're not a libertarian meeting i'm a
card-carrying member of the libertarian
party and i run around naked on stage
you know demanding that nobody has
driver's licenses but you either believe
in individual liberty you can figure out
the best way to live your life and the
government should basically stay out of
the way and do some minimal stuff and
that's it or you believe in the machine
you believe that some machine if we just
gave it enough money and enough power
and enough purview over all of our
ability to think and act and everything
else that somehow us giving all of that
power to that thing could somehow govern
us better than we can actually govern
ourselves so that makes more sense to me
rather than left right or or democrat
versus republican because none of jfk
would be a republican now no question
about it he would be a republican he was
cutting taxes he was anti-war
right he he had he was a patriot um he
was hated by the machine and maybe the
machine killed him you talked to oliver
stone i mean you know
so so those the whole thing has shifted
in a really bizarre way but to answer
who's winning
um i think the right broadly if we're
just using the right left thing uh is is
really starting to win i think the woke
thing is so out of control
this nonsense don't say gay stuff the
critical race stuff they're attacking
people's children now it was one thing
to lock people in their homes confuse
them about economics all of that stuff
but when you see cities burning and the
riots that we had by the way we don't
you know it's really odd since trump
left we don't have race riots anymore
it's almost as if there may be with some
coordination with someone yeah i don't
know it's alex jones a lot of stuff you
know um but i think they've gone so far
on everything so far in everything a
supreme court justice nominee can't say
what a woman is it's so bananas that i
think average people are just like i've
had enough of this and and what that
leaves you with is what i say on my show
all the time you don't have to be a
republican but you cannot be a democrat
i think that's basically where we're at
dave so for you
when you talk about your story and
you're transitioning you talk about sam
harris and bill maher and ben affleck so
that's one of when they had the muslim
no who are you are you now the say all
be all and you know everything about
this well i kind of am over qualified to
talk about this yeah and then you say
larry elder which you and larry elder
sat down and said you know there is a
little bit of racism tell me what tell
me what tell me the data tell me the
data with this there was this many
fifteen thousand seven thousand black on
black tell me what data and you're like
well you know but tell me you asked the
question you could so that was an
interesting moment and then you also
in regards to the topic with atheists
you know while jordan peterson kind of
influenced you know maybe not being an
atheist okay so
we're all influenced by certain people
that change our beliefs all of us i am
you are we all are
who influenced jenk when you saw the
process to go from republican to
independent to them to bernie how does
that influence take place
so first let me just say broadly
speaking about jank which i you know i
don't really do i really don't i'm happy
to i said yeah before we started you can
talk about absolutely anything it's
totally fine they've done a gajillion
videos lying about me and and maligning
me and all this stuff you can i've never
done a video about them period since i
left not one um so i just want to put
that out there it's just
because there's a little bit of
asymmetry it just doesn't matter to me i
was part of something it didn't end well
i think seeing that sort of hysteria and
that that moment with sam and everything
it really did wake me up so i'm grateful
for that you know it's one of those
things i look back i don't think that
fondly of the whole experience but man
it woke me up and life's been good since
and i evolved and that's all good so to
answer your question specifically by the
time i got there in 2013 he was already
a lefty and a bernie guy so i don't know
that much about his shift
from republican or conservative let's
say in college to what got him there but
i think what you said before is right
it's really hard to track a human being
that goes in that direction as they get
older meaning most people you become
more conservative meaning you start
realizing that life is sort of up to you
that you know you that you don't want
that much interference in your life
all of those things and as a businessman
which i suppose he purports to be a
businessman i mean he's running a
network it really makes no sense because
you want low taxes so that you can
invest more i mean look look what you
guys are building freaking extraordinary
so you would want all of the ideas that
i started to come around to the more
libertarian conservative ideas i just
started putting them into my life so
when larry elder smacked me around that
day that started a process even though
we were talking really about race it
started a process that got me
reading thomas soul books and then
ultimately interviewing thomas which is
probably the greatest thrill of my
career um it started it started a
process of opening myself up to these
ideas and then it and then the path is
kind of is kind of obvious you just go
down that path someone that goes the
other way
i just don't understand how you get
older and you're like no no the system
should do it more for us or no the
government needs more of our money or
any of those things i will say this
honestly i haven't watched a show of his
in years i don't know that he really
believes it in his heart of hearts i
don't yeah so i asked this question
because i'm wondering the only way i
think somebody goes further that side is
someone offended you okay someone
someone somewhere
and by the way listen reagan was
offended if you think about why reagan
reagan was partly if you really study
the story of reagan he was offended if
you study the history of and i know i
don't want to drop reagan and hitler the
same name hitler was offended you got
you know elizabeth warren was offended a
lot of people were offended like oh my
gosh i can't believe you did and then
you go do it but you don't necessarily
know if you're doing the right thing
just because the person that offended
you
so you're flipping no matter what that
offense could be a mom could be a dad
could be an ex could be a friend could
be a co-worker it could be a former
investor could be a lot of different
things
in that moment when you're offended i
think if you react too emotionally
you may all of a sudden pick up belief
systems that are not aligned with you
and then what oozes out is bitterness
and when bitterness oozes out i don't
wanna
you know we have a hard time we all got
relatives and we're bitter at some phase
of our lives we've probably been better
it's like people are like listen i just
don't like to be around you lately why
because i don't know it feels like
everybody's upsetting you you're fusing
so sure i'm like man am i really like
that bro it's hard to be around you
lately let's go okay cool well thank you
for telling me that and we kind of
figure out a way to improve because i do
think
jank and i have never had dinner before
we've never gone out before we've never
done anything like that before we simply
that was our first sit-down we've never
hadn't had a conversation prior to that
um
i walked when i said
this is a this guy's got a great
processor he's very witty he's fast
he he knows how to troll you and poke
because he's an expert at doing that
this guy uh
i don't know if maybe he needs to have
the moment that maybe you had i don't
know well i'm speculating but i actually
think you're making a great point on the
offense part and could something be so
personal that causes your whole way of
thinking to crack i think the sam moment
that you brought up i remember i mean i
was working there at the time and i was
having my wake-up call at that moment
when i saw that real-time moment like
that was all my frustrations with what
the left was becoming because i was
working for these guys and everybody
that disagreed with them was a racist
and a big in a homophobe and i was like
none of this makes sense it can't be
that we're all so right us lefties we're
so right about everything and not only
are we so right but everyone who we
disagree with is literally the worst
person in the world so that moment woke
me up and then you may have seen it sam
came to the studio oh yeah did this
three-hour conversation sam sits there
quietly calm down
you're saying yeah and jank is sweating
and the papers are flying all over the
place and there's a moment i think it's
that moment 19 if people want minute 19
if people want to see it where sam says
something about probability theory and
jank basically says i don't believe in
it
that's like saying you don't believe in
gravity i mean
it's real whether you believe it or not
it's it's happening right now but i
think yeah that thing kind of broke him
in in a bizarre way and that really was
that was the beginning of the end for me
that was in the fall of i think 2014 if
i'm not mistaken and i left in january
of 2015. because at that moment i was
like i can't work for this guy anymore i
just
i was already shifting politically but
it's not easy to just give up your job i
wasn't making a lot of money but it was
like it was my job um but over those
months i was just like enough enough can
i say something that i learned about jen
because i haven't watched uh the young
turks in years and years and years
um
that guy's an emotional dude yeah okay
and if there's anything that i've
learned from being you know sitting
right next to pat for the last few years
it's to try to try your best to be more
logical than emotional yeah and um
what we learned about number one i
thought he was a cool dude like i think
we could go have a beer with that guy
watch a sports game like actually kick
it with the guy would you disagree
there's a big difference between a
relationship like that until you make
the transition into money and boss and
that i'm not even taking a workaround
okay like if we went to dinner and we
watched the game i think she showed up
i went to his house to watch basketball
so i um
you know so i try because i'm
i've like the transition that you've
gone through dave yeah i'm going through
it i i know the story well okay i'm here
to finish the job by the way thank you
buddy yeah i was disgusted
but a lot of it is you know logical and
stuff that you've been you know fed for
years and years and years it's not like
you know like candice owens she went
through something very similar the red
pill black all that i saw your interview
with her yeah but with jank
and here's something that he did that i
probably wouldn't have done two years
ago when we brought up trump he trumps a
[ __ ] [ __ ] and he got he got super
emotional and me who traditionally would
have been that person two years ago was
like jank
just can i that wasn't his style two
years ago no yeah
i was like jake are you telling me that
it's
like he's zero percent done anything
right like i'm at least willing to say
i'm not a trump guy at all but i'm at
least willing to give credit where
credit is due yeah and if there's things
that he's done that are that are good
that have helped
you know the country the world whatever
i'm willing to do and if there's things
that are bad so it's there's a lot of
gray area there but to be some
completely black and white about
anything
and to what is it like to dig in yeah
and double down
uh that's hard to do and then i'm kind
of putting together your timeline you
know i said he's saying he's a bernie
guy well bernie didn't really hit the
national scene until 2015 2016. you had
left by 2014 or something around there
yeah 20. so
he probably was
in his methodology at that point and
then boom bernie comes along in 2016.
and he becomes the largest bernie
advocate out there right you but also
the part of that that you gotta
understand is that then the woke part
got in too bernie was doing an economic
populist thing you could agree with it
or disagree with it i obviously disagree
with it although some of his the broad
high level points make some sense to me
but the policies of just taxation and
more for the government make no sense to
me but the the deal with the devil that
i think the left has done is that they
took socialist economics and then they
combined it with woke with what is
cultural marxism this idea that your
your deficiencies or your immutable
characteristics or your whatever you
want to call it are the most important
thing about you so they combine
something that makes no sense and that's
why they're all so hysterical all the
time but i will tell you uh one thing on
the on the emotional side of this so
jank and i and a whole bunch of guys
that worked for tyt used to play
basketball every sunday every sunday
from about seven a.m to noon five hours
nice busting our asses you got some game
day i'm pretty damn good
actually you know what do you guys play
he's very good come down i got a full
court at my house come down you got to
do serious i i'm pulling i'm pulling
together a great game in miami anyway i
have a torn acl on my left knee though
so i got to play with one of those
freaking trap jaw braces sucks but all
right you and francis nagano both with
the tornado who was here yesterday
though ufc
champion of the world is that right i
did it believe it or not i did it the
last time i played with jank the last
time i played with jank i was going to
block a shot it was 10 to 10 games to
11. it wasn't it wasn't win by two and a
guy had a breakaway and i blocked i did
block the shot but i came down tore my
acl that was five years ago anyway uh
but we played this game every sunday
busting our asses i loved it i loved it
more than anything else like that's
where i'm truly at my happiest and jank
was the most emotional screaming like
the worst type of person you would ever
want to play basketball every call that
didn't go his way screaming he'd kick
the basketball screen and i kid you not
it was across the street from a very
very famous church in l.a i'll tell you
guys off off the camera because i want
to say exactly where it was
and twice we played on sundays twice
police had to come to the court
to ask him to stop screaming
because people were going to church on
sunday mornings that so that sort of
tells you what you need to know about
the overly emotional part of yeah but
it's like it's like a seventh grader
playing basketball like you don't when
you're an adult and you're all out there
like trying to have fun and not
basically blow out our knee or break our
neck right stop screaming at everybody
what is the basketball court you're
gonna give it away yeah i don't want to
fully out i'll tell you guys later so so
church at the open door but listen i
will tell you i will tell you super
super super competitive guy he's a super
competitive guy and when you're super
super competitive you there's nobody if
you don't take control of that
competitive spirit it's going to get the
worst out of you you gotta somehow take
control of it uh and and learn how to
manage that energy but it is what it is
appreciate you for bringing it up you're
gonna like playing with this guy because
uh he was one cut away from getting into
the nba shaun c phillips's nephew got
the position over him to get into the
nba literally true story wait this is
literal this is a literal story he was
on uh i used to be a baller yeah
chris humphreys
when chris humphries married kim
kardashian he was one of the groomsmen
he was on yeah so he know he actually
he's the best jewish athlete in miami
that's all you need to know so i'll tell
you i can't do this one on camera either
but my house that i bought here was
owned by an nba player that's how that's
why i got this pretty sick court cool
he's probably going to know who it is
because he parties with all those guys
in miami so anyway
you guys will do that so appreciate you
for being a sport and talking about it
and i know sometimes listen
four things four things you do in life
that changes the relationship and you
have to be mature to be able to manage
it one the moment you have sex with
somebody changes a relationship too the
moment you go into business with
somebody can be your best friend changes
a relationship three the moment you
travel with somebody and share rooms it
changes the relationship and four the
moment you pay somebody it changes the
relationship goes to another level tom
and i
we've traveled together god knows how
many years 15 years we've been traveling
together tom and i i need to point out
that we only checked off three of them
[Music]
why don't we go right into that since
yeah since you guys are talking about
you brought it up a little bit so new
york's mayor eric adams here's a
huffpost story to floridians
come here
where you can say gay okay so that's his
marketing
campaign i i want to see if you think
this is an effective marketing campaign
or not new york city is launching a
digital billboard campaign to lure
floridians unhappy with their state
don't say gay law to the big apple mayor
eric adams announced monday the
billboard supporting lgbtq visibility
will be displayed on five major markets
in florida for eight weeks starting
monday this is the city of stonewall
this is the city where we are proud to
talk about how you can live in a
comfortable setting and not be harassed
and not be abused not only as adults but
also as young people adam said the
announcement came one week after florida
governor ron desantis signed a bill into
a law that forbids instruction on sexual
orientation and gender identity in
kindergarten through third grade is this
a good marketing campaign
so first off yeah i had about an hour
drive to get here this morning i did
pass a giant gay billboard
what's the main road here i'm still
allowed
on
i don't know if it was the new york city
one we just it just there's a black
billboard white letter's gay you're just
trying to have gays
zippity doodah so
first off as i'm sure you guys know uh
and so feel free to stop me if you've
already done this 100 times in the show
this entire bill
is completely sensible there is it's
hb1557 this is about not teaching
young kids k through 3 about gender
identity and sexuality but you could
have the media lies about everything you
could have just as easily called it
don't say straight because you wouldn't
want a straight teacher telling a first
grader privately about straight sex or
gender identity and then hiding it from
the parents so it's fully about
transparency so it's it's just obvious
and decent let me just say something
else on this which is that everyone's
running around desantis hates gays baba
i happen to be gay i am married to a
dude okay we're having kids you know
what that what showed up at my door two
days ago
a package with two wherever two babies
with two baby onesies from ron desantis
okay he does not hate gay people at this
prageru event that i mentioned before i
introduced i said governor this is my
husband david
big hug smile took a picture
congratulations on the kid this has
nothing to do with an assault on gay
rights if desantis was saying gay people
can't get married gay people can't work
whatever the litany of stupidity that
these people think
of course i would be against it there's
nothing i stand for more than equal
rights for everybody it has no this is
about indoctrinating children
and and eric adams i mean the funny
thing about him is you thought new york
city couldn't get worse under socialist
lunatic bill de blasio that's what
people thought oh eric adams will clean
up the city and clean up the truck a lot
of people have insane no nope i mean
everything's completely collapsing in
new york city what is he talking about
none of it works and i think for you
whatever that last
five percent that you're trying to shave
off now
there's nothing that i have to do and
there's no crazy thing that jen can say
that will push you any further because
entropy will just move you there now
it's just once you see it you cannot
unsee it they lie
about
everything give me something that the
mainstream media has not lied about over
the last five years brett kavanaugh is a
serial rapist trump very fine people on
both sides uh
covington kids russia the hunter biden
laptop literally everything that has
been a cultural story or an important
moment in america
they have lied about and once you see it
then then actually you don't become
hysterical anymore one of the reasons
people are so hysterical is because the
reality that's going on in their brains
is disconnected from what the media is
telling them all the time yeah i will
say this
and i think the lying also yes i agree
yeah fully fox doesn't exactly tell the
truth all the time either no of course
not okay yeah i'm talking about
mainstream but this is
why shows like oh he said maybe the
reuben report
exactly yeah exactly this is the show
reason why
people like dave rubin people like
patrick bet david people like candace
owens people like ben shapiro people
like jordan peters this is why people
who are on the internet are getting
rogan hello are getting so much more
attention than traditional legacy media
i i say it on my show almost every day
and i swear to you i mean this i truly
mean this if these people would just get
better just don't be completely horrible
because that's what they are completely
harmed
if they would just get a little bit
better so that it was tolerable i am not
kidding i would do something else i
really mean that i love what i do i'm
sure it's exactly like you i wake up
every morning i'm sorry
psyched to do what i do i love it i'm
enjoying it now more than ever actually
but truly if if if it all started fixing
itself if the machine could reorder
itself and it was really doing something
okay
there's other things that i like to do
too and like play basketball like i
would i would go you know what i'd be
the number one star in the wnba
i'm not kidding man 45 years old torn
acl
i'd be scoring 35 points a game in the
wnba let me ask you a question
tom i don't know if i asked actually i
didn't ask you were not when i asked
this question so
how old were you in school
when a teacher started teaching
about different genders including gay
how old were both of you like what grade
was it when sex had started and what
what grade was it when you learned
here's what's a lesbian here's what's
gay here's what's straight here's what's
this for you in high school what year
was it uh i i was 16 i was a sophomore
and it wasn't about gender then it was
about straight or gay that's what it was
helping guidance uh
yeah it's the class and they touched on
remember this is 16. this is nine i was
16 so it's 1978 and so it was softly
touched on this is also when jimmy
carter was causing hurricanes in the
economy right and an ex-democrat named
ronald reagan was about to be elected
president people have to remember reagan
was a democrat and he went the opposite
way
that our fred cheng did yeah and so
that's that's when you heard about it
and also in florida i'll say this you
know what just talk about dishonesty um
you know and i'll bridge back to this
there's been a thriving community in key
west or south beach
since i was 16 and it was not in the
closet and it was not some over-the-top
you know socially inappropriate
caricature it was just a thriving
community that's all it was and you know
greenwich village west hollywood and san
francisco had nothing on florida you
know i think florida that's it's
actually been easier to be out since the
70s and 80s you were here 16 in florida
so yeah your health and guidance class
was in the state of florida and they
taught you about straight and gay and i
yes right and i would notice when we
would go down the party or whatever you
would see south beach and and key west
it it wasn't they weren't closeted it
was it was this is who i am and this is
our community around our neighborhood
here and you would sit there you go down
to um key west sloppy joe's has been
there for a thousand years you know the
hemingway bar and then when i went
interestingly
i go to california i don't even know
these places for the record you're gonna
you're gonna find out yeah i'm sure i'm
really gay with one guy that's pretty
much it for me you know but that's great
that they have their own bars now yeah
separate buddy but the point is we're
talking 70s 80s where it was okay to be
out it wasn't that quiet you're in this
neighborhood no it wasn't and then i go
out to i guess that's studio 54 era or
no
but that was more in new york city new
york but it was like you know new york
florida it's right similar and so that
but that's what it was it was 16 you
know there was there
was a political us
you know people politically ostracize
you know i think there is a little of
that you're also dealing with the time
in anita bryant here's what i want to
know what what i'm specifically asking
about is what age did you learn
in school
straight gay sex set what age was that
so you said success
so i don't know that well i know that i
had my first health class in seventh
grade with the condom on the banana and
that thing i don't i honestly don't
remember them discussing anything about
straight or gay i don't think there was
oh some people are gay perhaps there was
i actually have no recollection but also
what does this have to do with education
is the real issue you know for putting
aside this k through three third grade
thing which is absolutely insane
as we've watched so many teachers become
activists as opposed to teachers what
does this have to do with education you
have kids right right you have four kids
how old are they ten eight to five and
nine months okay
so you are the living perfect example of
this do your kids go to public or
private you don't mind okay yeah and i
don't blame you of course right so but
imagine you you were sending your kids
to public school and your five-year-old
who's kindergarten right so five
kindergarten imagine you found out that
the teacher putting aside gay straight
or anything else the teacher was having
some discussion with your five-year-old
about something related to gender or sex
or their own relationship or something
it makes no
sense does that make sense at any level
and what would you do if you found that
out
you're going to see a very bad side of
me yeah you'll see the jinx
you would see the very bad side i mean
that that doesn't come out often but now
is that because you're a bigot or you're
a homophobe or you're a no that's
because that's none of your business to
talk to my kids about that age because
they're not adults yet don't confuse
them
i have to yesterday we're at the house
and we're having a debate because
uh the kids had a batman marathon this
weekend so they started with batman
begins then it was the
good ones
the good ones
so tico is coming telling me his
classmate yasser just watched the last
batman that came out right the three
hour one daddy i want to watch it he had
a chance to watch it why can't i watch
it i said let me go watch it first i
watch it and i said
man listen i
okay we'll watch it together we're gonna
go so we're gonna go watch it together
but it's a discussion that we made as a
family yesterday at the dinner to time
you were there when we were talking
about it and mario was sitting i said
okay i'll take these guys right these
guys watch scent of a woman if you can
watch the scent of a woman you can watch
a lot of things because that was a great
character so but going back to what you
just said which is very important you're
saying why does that even belong in
education why does that even and this is
coming from somebody who's sex who's gay
married you're saying you're about to
have kids and you're saying this so yeah
you're not even imposing saying no we
need to teach that at this level
it just makes no sense it it everyone
knows it that's the thing we all know it
and they this is what they do they get
the meme it's called hb one five five
seven but did any of you know that
actually
you knew it of course in florida right
but most people don't know it if if you
asked 90 of the american electorate
about don't say gay first they would
tell you something almost all of them
would tell you something that's not true
but they would have no idea what the
bill is actually called and then if you
said to them what i just said to you
well would you want your six-year-old to
talk to a state employee about sex and
then be
allow the state employee to not tell you
about that conversation and potentially
call that kid another name by
everyone would say no and yet we debate
this as if it's honestly something to
debate so so then you know what this
does so you remember the conversation
about the right pulling to the right the
left pulling to the left and you got the
center and we're talking about how jank
is going how do you go further to the
left as you age and yeah did somebody
find all this other stuff this is where
uh i think common sense prevails and not
with everybody and you don't need
everybody there's this notion that you
need to convert everybody you do not you
only need to convert
five percent of the population eight
percent of the population to go left or
right you don't need the whole world to
say you make a lot of sense and just
because somebody is louder than another
person that doesn't mean that's how
exactly seventy percent of america is
thinking seventy percent of america is
sitting there with their kids they're
thinking listen i'm not with that they
can say that all they want just because
that video went viral got 82 million
viewers i don't really care that thing
got viral on tick tock i care about
these principles i want to raise my kids
right rogan had an experience he talked
about with his uh nine-year-old child in
california i don't know if you heard
about it
this morning yeah so so there's this
this story i'll read it to you hang on
one second so joe rogan reveals
that woke anti-racist ideology was
pushed on his nine-year-old child in
california school this was a
post-millennial story when the whole
george floyd thing happened one of the
schools that my kids were going to back
in california released this email saying
that it's not enough to not be racist
you now must be anti-racist and my kids
nine at the time what does that what
does this even mean rogan asked on
tuesday's episode on the joe oregon
experience these kids are not even
remotely racist like they have all sorts
of different kinds of friends i've never
heard them discuss it once it's just
like this person and she's nice to me
and we like to play together and we both
like the same things and so tell a
nine-year-old that you have to be
anti-racist well then they go looking
for racism they're gonna be looking to
confront it
that sounds very logical and common
sense to me how do you process what joe
was saying but i thought we were told
they don't teach critical race theory in
schools isn't that the meme out there oh
it's only these right-wingers making it
up that we're that we're teaching this
stuff in schools and yet here is joe
rogan obviously giving you an honest
assessment of what's going on there and
i don't know if you guys follow chris
ruffo by chance but chris ruffo is
basically the leader i believe he works
at the manhattan institute but he is the
leader at exposing what is going on with
critical race theory at all of these
schools what's on the show with msnbc
what's her name him and him and her
going back and forth with that woman
who's broadcasting from a mental
institution
you know if you watch msnbc and you just
pretend that they're in a mental
institution it's actually quite
watchable if you watch it as a news
program it's pretty awful um but look we
know this stuff is going on and guess
who's going to fight it it's going to be
desantis they'll fight it in texas where
joe rogan what did he do he fled
california and he went to texas um the
funny thing about rogan is that rogan
was a bernie supporter and yet when he
signed the 200 million deal with spotify
what was the first thing he did he got
the hell out of california had something
to do with the taxes so we all have like
you know some inconsistencies in in how
we behave or what we talk about versus
how we actually
are uh but this stuff is obviously going
on they we almost killed racism in
america we almost how old are you all
you guys 43. so we're all ballparking
forty-two ish forty fifteen fifty right
okay
we all of us grew up in a world that
racism was pretty much done it really
think about ten years ago was there any
real mainstream racist person or racist
idea that was running rampant there
really wasn't
and maybe maybe the you of three years
ago thought that trump was like the the
racist instigator to me he was actually
the reverse of that completely he was of
all the things i thought of trump racist
wasn't at the top of the list okay fair
enough and we don't have to bother
wasting time on trump but the point is
the who's who's racist in america now
it's the anti-racist it's the people who
purport to be the tolerant ones that are
injecting race and gender and sexuality
and all of our differences into
everything there is literally
imagine how insane this would be show me
a republican show me the craziest far
right marjorie taylor green
something republican
and tell me what racist policy she has
does she not want black people to have
the same go to the same water fountains
or be able to get jobs it's you know
who's instigating racism it's the left
who want coveted vaccines to be decided
by race it's the left who wants harvard
to actually have quotas to stop asians
from coming in you know this crazy story
we had them on we had the young kid who
wrote wrote a book about it
extraordinary there's a three-year
lawsuit at yale about that yeah so it's
like
who who actually are the racist who
actually are the homophobes trust me i'm
not being hunted down here in florida as
you just pointed out it's like it's
completely fine it's completely fine but
they're ushering it back in we almost
did it we got it to this and now they're
starting to expand it again well let's
not forget this all started with uh
president obama race relations in
america were better under george bush
pre obama than they were obama coming in
uh trayvon martin could have been my son
the dallas
the funeral for the dallas police
officers all there's institutional
racism in the police department like he
ushered all this stuff back in there
were the riots in what uh not
minneapolis but baltimore baltimore
riots under under obama like this all
started with him this all starts in the
universities and that's like
like you said common sense is winning
it's not left it's not right it's those
who want to be free and left alone and
they see things like remember the san
francisco choir that they they said it
was a joke but they were coming for
right it's things like that the people
are they're just done that's why by the
way then it turned out it turned out
like three of those guys were had been
arrested for pedophilia or something i
mean really like bananas stuff yeah
that's awkward yeah and it's like you
see terry mcauliffe in virginia people
are just sick of it they just want to be
left alone it's not left it's not right
it's like you said pat it's common sense
well back to you what's interesting
about the school is that you know what
i'm not even getting political with it
you know what a losing proposition is
messing with someone's kids yep like
whether you're a democrat whether you're
republican whether you're pro-capitalism
socialism at some point if someone
starts messing with your kids all
ideology is out the freaking window and
it's like don't mess with my freaking
kids here yeah ask terry mcauliffe yeah
well exactly that's the elect that
election went
click bang boom in two weeks
let me let me tell you so i i i'm gonna
butcher who this was if i'm trying to
find the story to kind of tell you
exactly where this is coming from so
they went to this
community and this i don't know i want
to say indian reservation but maybe it's
a different one and they noticed one
thing that nobody in that city stuttered
like wait a minute this is very weird
how come nobody stutters here
and
they go around they're asking everybody
how come nobody stutters how come nobody
stutters how come nobody stutters how
come nobody stutters and everybody
starts saying what's stutter
what do you mean what stutter what does
the word stutter mean
what do you you really don't know what
the word stutter means no i don't know
what the word study means they go look
into their dictionary the word stutter
is not in their dictionary meaning
since they didn't know that there was
such a thing as stuttering people
stopped stuttering nobody stuttered
the moment you put that in there we
start thinking and we start stuttering
now how much truth there is behind this
i haven't spent my entire life
investigating this but there's a part
around it that validates a point of the
power of affirmations if you keep
telling me i'm a loser i'm eventually
gonna believe it if you keep telling me
i'm not gonna amount to anything i'm
eventually gonna believe it if you keep
telling me i'm gonna do something
special in my life maybe i have the
ability to use all my talents and
abilities to do something big in my life
maybe i'm going to start believing it if
you start telling america we're racist
maybe a small popular popular small
percent is going to start believing it
then we are going to start being racist
if you tell us we get along and we're
making progress we're going to be like
oh what's up dave you're gay you're
getting married 40 years ago i don't
know today dude let's chill i'm from
iran oh you're from iran oh you're from
iran hey what are you having exactly hey
are we really going to do this in a you
know in a uh what do you call this place
in a bank vault and you're going to
close that i don't trust you but an
iranian but you know what let's do it
hey an iranian and a jew are sitting
right next to each other now it's like
it's okay but that this whole concept of
africa over and over and over maybe i do
have problems maybe america does have
problems i think that is one of the
biggest problems we have they keep
repeating the same [ __ ] and some are
starting to believe it have you ever
seen that incredible if you haven't seen
it you gotta you gotta show it to your
audience morgan freeman saying exactly
what you said
uh did you do oh there's one that he did
with lemon and there's one from i think
uh a few years before that he did on 60
minutes with uh ed bradley uh not ed
bradley the other guy mike wallace mike
wallace yeah thank you um it's it's an
absolutely and that's exactly what he
says stop talking about it
congratulations we'll move on and then
there's a great moment where uh
uh mike wallace is like well but don't
you want black history month and he
turns to him and he's like don't you
want white history month and he goes
well actually i'm jewish and he goes
well do you want jewish history month
and he's like no like his gut reaction
give it to me yeah and then he says it's
just can i tell you why your point is so
powerful about the stuttering thing yeah
um because i i have a real life case
example about that i my freshman year i
played football in college right and the
quarterback on the team my buddy i was a
wide receiver and my buddy lived at the
place next door
had had a had a had a horrible
horrible stutter
okay
his name was
tommy waters would stutter like crazy
okay
but when he would go into the huddle all
right guys here's the play today here we
go i was like what the [ __ ] is this wow
but i hung out with him so much
and i didn't realize that i came back
home to miami for spring break or
whatever it was
and my friends are like dude why are you
stuttering wow and i was like what are
you talking about but i hung out with
him so much that i developed a stutter
and then like my friends and nobody
called me out in in school at college
because it was like i was with tommy
that was my boy
and shout out to tommy if you're
watching this he's the best
um
and my friend's like dude you
you're a stutterer now and i had to like
hold on
yeah i don't i don't stutter and i'm
just gonna start talking regularly but
it's osmosis if you're around people are
like oh the people are racist this is
what's happening you're gonna start
thinking about it so your stuttering
thing is a very real life example of
what can happen when you're crammed down
your throat with critical race theory or
wokeness or racism
you're you start to live it so think
about that that's you in college right
now this we have all the adults going
through this through the media but now
to connect this to the rogan thing he's
talking about his nine-year-old kid
right so now a nine-year-old kid you
everyone knows this they don't care
about race they don't think about sex
they just want to play and now you
suddenly are injecting racism into their
world at nine years old
they are literally literally
manufacturing tomorrow's racists we had
got there we were done
nobody there was no really try to think
who who in mainstream america in the
last 20 years was truly racist promoting
racism that really wanted laws to be
true that was maybe david duke
yeah i don't even know that he was
manchester united he wasn't mainstream i
don't even know if the guy's alive
anymore but yeah but there it was done
but now they are
keep creating a situation where
nine-year-olds
where nine-year-olds will have the idea
of race in their head when when there's
i can you imagine if joe rogan is
sending his kid to a school where racism
is rampant i mean every school in l.a
they proudly smack that we're
anti-racist here and it's like man were
you guys racist three years ago what was
going on over there there's a whole
racist baby that came up in the supreme
court uh
justice hearings racism
i think i might have missed this cruz
was talking about this by the way let me
tell you let me tell you what i saw the
other day i saw i saw this story i'm
like oh tyler check this out to see if
this story is true or not so this kid
17 year old kid i don't know if you
heard about this or not the 17th oh my
god this story is suing his parents for
being born white did you hear about this
i didn't hear about it so let's talk
about i don't know how old this story is
though but but still like but but here's
the concept of his rejection but here's
the point this is becoming more and more
i saw another one on this 17 year old
teenager susan's parents were being born
white anthony dwight 17 claims he has
suffered his whole life from the shame
of being born white when i was a kid i'd
spent hours in the shower trying to wash
off my white skin but it would never go
away isn't there enough white people on
this planet haven't we
inflicted enough suffering racism and
depression in this world the young man's
lawyer robert huffman claims his client
has suffered severe psychological
distress symptoms of depression and
suicidal
tendencies because of what he calls the
burden of being white privileged because
a level of psychological distress on my
client we ask that his parents pay for
all the necessary expenses to change his
racial status including skin coloring
treatments
how to help okay first off that lawyer
needs to be disbarred immediately the
the lawyer that picks up the yes i'm
gonna sue your parents for your skin
color that lawyer needs to be mocked
into oblivion putting aside the rest of
this ridiculous story obviously
but you see what they did
congratulations you made some 17 year
old kid he was just a kid
congratulations he hates himself this is
it any way you cut it whether this was a
black kid an asian kid a white kid
native american kid a jewish kid yep
like it's just sad any way you cut it so
but but the question becomes the
following how did this kid come to that
conclusion okay who reaffirmed something
to him over it's definitely not his
parents who reaffirmed and caused that
hate to him the entire machine so why is
this white bad you bad quite bad but you
better but all of a sudden let's
actually speculate let's actually
speculate do you think the 17 year old
kid is watching msnbc or cnn or fox no
okay so do you think this would have
been from one of his classmates that
yeah
do you think this could have been from
one of the teachers or people
okay so he was the same this uh st louis
i think so but the point is somebody put
that thought in this kid's head period
somebody put that thought in this kid's
head and he has to kind of live up by
that my biggest concern with what's
going on with kids i said this the other
day is i'm not worried about me i'm
going to be able to afford to do
homeschooling or hire the best teachers
to teach my kids at my house and hey
just come down we'll hire three four
teachers every you guys just come and
rotate we'll pay a hundred bucks an hour
come and do it but forget about me i've
busted the last 20 years to be in this
situation so if things got really
ridiculous i can at least be able to
influence my kids properly by hiring the
right teachers how about the other 98
percent of america that 95 of america
that can't afford to send their kids to
private school that they have to
leverage and just lean on public schools
that they can't change zoning they don't
have a choice
they have to go through the only choice
they have is either doing homeschooling
or try to control as much as possible um
which by the way it was crazy who was it
we had on that said the need for church
has increased oh yesterday i got this
random call did i tell you about that
yeah i told you about this random call i
got yesterday i'm at the baseball field
with dylan
this i get this call from illinois i'm
like who is this and you know my phone's
not saved the number so i pick it up is
this the one i saw you at the guard gate
no no no that's that's a prank i was
pulling on you that's a different one we
pulled a very good prank
on him and it has to do with something
it has to do with you i'll tell that
story in a minute but this guy calls me
so i call back
is this patrick
who's calling oh the one word yeah is
this patrick
i'm sorry who's colin it is patrick okay
patrick i said who's colin i can't tell
you my name because i don't want you to
ever talk about this on your podcast but
i watch all your stuff so the reason why
i'm calling you is because the interview
i watch with jack barski
and i'm like jack barski kgb yes
and he says what is the difference
between the old testament and the new
testament
i said what's the context behind this
question he says what is the difference
between the old it's one word what is
the difference between old testament and
newtonism i'm like
old testament you believe in that jewish
new testament christian no it's one word
i said are you saying jesus
bingo is jesus
i said what does kgb jack barsky have to
do with jesus
so he goes for 15 minutes i'm sitting
i'm like i can't even believe i'm
entertaining this conversation how'd you
get my phone the whole premise of his
call to say that america needs god today
that was his whole premise and by the
way
we hung up we had a great conversation
say i love you but i'll follow him just
don't give my name don't give me i'm
like i'm not going to give you your
number on the live podcast he says i'm
still not going to give you my numbers
i'm totally fine now joel steen
old man by the way 65 year old man 65
reminds us i don't want to have because
i don't want to get persecution i said
aren't you just as guilty to be
embarrassed to talk about god as you are
judging others who are doing this i'm
sorry you are just as guilty because if
you're so proud of the belief on what's
god done for you why don't you be
publicly talking about it why are you
being a closet christian come on and
talk about i said well that's a fair
assessment but nowadays at my job i can
be persecuted i can lose my job bingo so
look at the fears you feed it people
have right look at what's going on but
again i said this two podcasts could go
i'm saying that again today
if you're raising a kid today
everything becomes an insurance policy
okay it's almost like okay
i'm gonna lean on sports to get my kids
as a positive distraction because a good
positive distraction is gonna get them
away from the other stuff a good private
school good friends you know good uncles
to have around i need to kind of rely on
a local church that i trust to have the
right values and principles all you're
looking at is putting that right defense
around you and the right values to be
taught and i actually in a weird way
this is going to sound crazy every you
know
talking about religion is not something
we talk about on our podcast
i think in the craziest way
i think the next 10 to 20 years churches
are going to blow up i don't know why i
think church is going to blow up the
next 10 or 20 years oh i'll tell you why
yeah well well first i just want to say
the craziest part of that story that you
just told is that you pick up numbers
that you don't recognize
is the most insane if i get a call
my phone number has been leaked so many
times and i've changed my phone
zero percent chance of picking that that
genuinely yes is this patrick how could
i what like that is the most crazy thing
i have ever heard i can only imagine how
to make you crazier yeah i'll make you
crazier i've not changed my number in 20
years
i'm telling you it's been my number for
20 years if someone just comes knocking
on your door they're just not going come
on in come on
you seem like a knife i'd like to talk
to you about god come on in
in the craziest way in the craziest way
this is gonna sound crazy
i i so love a good debate
and a good discourse wow you're living
your best life now i am living my best
living my best life how you enjoy your
good someone's phone number you
recognize like uh first of all don't you
don't recognize that watch me get 50
calls today
i'm not picking up today's call that's
also that's so it shows you how we're
all wired differently because so right
we do a very similar thing for a living
right so i run businesses outside but i
talk for a living so we do basically the
same thing i talk into so i wake up at 6
a.m and i'm basically talking till till
whatever day whatever time that shuts
down so it could be 8 pm i've talked all
day when when i'm done i almost to the
point that i cannot speak i turn on
seinfeld and i'm like that's it don't
talk to me but you what you just said
there is you love it so much i just do
and i don't think it's that you love it
more than me it's that we're wired
probably a little bit differently that
if i got a call from an anonymous number
at eight o'clock that would be the devil
to me and you're like yes let's continue
the conversation can't wait to talk to
this random person i mean that is
absolutely
by the way i'll give you one thing that
it's even funnier than this so when i
get random texts from people and i don't
recognize the number here's what i'll do
did you see what i did the other day
with the guy let me just can you call
them no no no let me tell you what i do
with them because them i have fun with
so guy text me says uh hey uh uh uh are
we gonna be able to see you later on
today and i texted this guy back no joke
you should see this i should show this
guy's number and put it on the screen i
respond back i said um did kamala tell
you i won't be making it
so the guy's like excuse me i say yeah
just tell kamala i can't make it because
joe will be upset but kamala knows what
i'm going through right now and then he
responds back saying i'm just a
valuetainer man are you really talking
to kamala harris and i just leave the
text alone i don't respond back i wonder
what this guy is probably thinking about
saying pat's talking to kamala is
they're going to party but anyways going
back to yes the point you're gonna make
i think you're completely right i think
church
i'm actually i'm partly making this
argument in my book that because the
woke thing is so out of control and
because two plus two is five and boys
are girls and if you're not racist you
are racist because everything is so
backwards when everything's backwards
people need something to fall back on
and i i can feel this i can feel it and
i mean i thought i was an atheist five
or six years ago i'm not anymore i'm a
believer i toured with jordan peterson
he moved me on some on probably the most
important question of of all you know in
essence um i think a lot of people are
going to go that direction it's a sad
state in a way because because
liberalism in its truest form should be
able to stand on its own but but the
left has destroyed liberalism
change things so that words have no
meaning anymore and then people will go
to religion i'm actually not saying that
religion is bad i i'm not saying that at
all actually i think at the end
societies somehow need an organizing
principle and i don't know that there is
one better than belief at some level uh
but i i completely agree with you and
are you you're jewish yeah go to temples
where do you go um
you know it's funny i i've sort of come
back towards it dennis prager actually
helped me a lot on this he ran in la
he he's not a rabbi technically but he
was running services and runs sort of
like a it's sort of like a misfit temple
and i started going and i you know i
dennis has been a mentor and a friend
and everything else and he brought me
back to a lot of that but you know for
jews i'm sure it's somewhat similar to
you
it's become more of a culture and a way
of thinking and a sense of humor and
holy [ __ ] we survived somehow five
thousand years of this lunacy and
there's still a couple of us left
so but i am trying to figure out how
that piece is into my life well
regarding regarding church religion
ultimately what we're talking about i
think is just a bigger sense of purpose
and meaning in life
ultimately we're all just trying to
figure out what the hell are we doing
here like how what is life what is the
meaning of life
and
i mean look at the stats the most common
religion now is
non-believer yeah right so
god has been taken out of society and
i'm not religious but i i will say that
i do
and this might just because of my
upbringing and my mom you could do
whatever you want to do and yeah
affirmation and like a typical jewish
mom
but
for most people in america they don't
have necessarily a higher sense of
purpose or meaning and kova has
exacerbated that you're stuck at home
alone you lost your job you don't know
what's going on you're taking opioids
you're you're looking at everyone on tv
and on social media everyone's doing
amazing and you're just stuck in this
you know shitty life and if you're if
there's nothing to cling on to for
religion what do you have and a lot of
people cling on to politics you know
especially even on the left these days
but that's true that's why you have to
give the woke credit because they turned
a political ideology into a cult
you cannot get out of that cult it's why
so many of them go so crazy why is jon
stewart right now
screaming about white people all the
time it's because he went into the woke
thing and then once you're in it jon
stewart knows he's a hundred million
dollar white guy middle-aged white guy
in essence right so he has to keep going
otherwise they'll turn on him too
it's a religion that you cannot leave
and he's what you would call and i
learned this term literally from you
dave
a classic liberal he he should be truly
i don't think he's in his true
head i don't think he's a crazy woke
leftist right but just you know i don't
know that anyone's watching he's gone
down that path yeah doing bill maher
avoided that and stayed true to himself
i mean i do this on my show all the time
i'm so frustrated with bill maher i
really am yeah i'm supposed to be why
are you podcasting
because he's so freaking close he's so
damn close to getting it and then he
just shoots himself in the foot yes so
so bill maher he gets it on critical
race theory now he got it on kovid
finally two years too late but he got it
he gets it on the gender stuff he gets
it on free speech he gets all the big
ones
but until you're willing to say i will
not support and vote for people who have
ushered this all in
then you're then at some point you're no
longer doing a service right right it's
one thing to wake so you asked me before
where we started was about waking people
up and how do we move people well bill
maher i guess at some level he's woken
up some liberals right so that that is
good and by the way this is a guy who
i've loved and admired for for 20 years
but at the end
because of trump derangement syndrome
and his bingo by the way trump broke him
to the point that you can't you can't
say i'm against critical race there i'm
against all the gender stuff and then
it's like all right bill so when it came
down to it would you have voted for
glenn younkin or not and if the answer
is no you would have voted for terry
mcauliffe then you actually aren't at
the end of the road yet so he's getting
people almost to the promised land and
right when they get to the promised land
they're right there the border he then
takes them the other way so last week
you probably saw it he sat on a show he
said that the republicans would love if
there were no black supreme court
justices
uh you know there is a black supreme
court justice and he's a conservative
did you know that bill and everyone
loves him and i guarantee you
yeah he's an uncle tom and i guarantee
you that every conservative in the
country would love if there were 12 of
him so at the end
you get there and then all you got left
is but their race i think his problem
actually is that he's called so many
religious people crazy for 20 years
it's very hard for him to put that
together special called religious it's
not like yeah
but let me tell you exactly what's
happening with him yeah because i'm
living it yeah i got it he's going down
the road he's going to the path you said
he gets to the pearly gates and who's at
the gate bro it's trump that's
ultimately what's happening is you get
to the gate
and you're like hold on everything was
made so much sense and trump's at the
gate and this is why i think
the republicans will be shooting
themselves in the foot having trump come
back versus a desantis i think no matter
who desantis runs against landslide
if trump runs
anyone's guess i think tyler's got
something to tell us go ahead tyler well
you're just talking about the black
supreme court justice uh clarence thomas
let's not forget that george bush
nominated janice rogers the first black
woman to the supreme court and who shot
it down oh there was a guy afraid
now he's very confused yeah what's that
guy's name excuse me
we all live in the present and we don't
even open a history book who the hell is
thurgood marshall and who got him onto
the court and who didn't want him on the
court nobody wants to go back and look
at that nobody wants to go back and and
look at what was the real party of civil
rights why was the republican party
founded exactly
you know and people forget oh it'd be
the first
thurgood marshall i recall was an
amazing intellect he was an amazing
jurist
not because he was black because he was
an amazing jurist
and you'll look at how he ended up on
the court and all we'll look back and we
only want to put it in today's time
because they need it okay so check this
out we don't have legit we don't have
education we have agendication hold on
are you getting another call from an
anonymous
by the way
seriously somebody just text me from a
number i don't recognize saying patrick
great show i said tell kamala i said
hello
bye-bye here you go how the hell did you
get my number but anyway so here we go
a highly educated white military
president dwight david eisenhower
sends 101st airborne in to protect nine
people who had the right to go to the
high school that was in their
neighborhood not be bused across town
anyways by the way did you guys see uh
the the
how uh biden was the life of the party
just a couple days ago put it up there
how he was like everybody people he had
a line of people trying to talk to him
let's let's take a look at this if you
haven't seen this make that okay there
you go
do you have audio or no
okay if you want to put the audio put
the audio because it's c-span we're
paying for this
nobody wants to talk to him
i watch the way obama ignores him when
he puts the hand watch this
he knows the president of the united
states is touching him right now
he knows it and just look at that he's
leaning on him
okay so so let's let's process this
let's process this from three different
angles and i want to get your
perspective on this one
how do our enemies process that so putin
how do maybe you know uh and iran a
china xi not necessarily enemy but
they're not our allies right how does
what is barack obama's motive here is he
coming in and saying hello vice
president joe biden and he says this was
part of the skit we talked about it
undermining him and number
three biden himself is he sitting there
thinking in his own mind with nobody
telling him this not his advisers not
his peers nobody's saying
i think i may be replaced here right
after november midterms what give me
give it to me perspective from those
three lenses i think it frightens our
enemies because they look at this video
and they say oh my gosh
he has superpowers he can be invisible
and walk around a room this is a
dangerous guy tom this is why you could
only be a comedian around big
universities that have technical minds
but but go ahead what are you doing no i
was a pg orc fan
well first first i will address that but
did you guys see the video from about a
year or two ago we showed it on my show
i think yesterday of obama saying that
what his dream would be to have a third
term but he would just need a dummy out
there and he would just be able to talk
to them in their ear basically he would
just need a body he said that two years
yeah i'll send you the video later he
said it about a year ago that would be
his true dream he would love a third
term where he was the puppet master
he's kind of yeah he just saw it right
there ladies and gentlemen charlie
mccarthy by the way i'm totally cool
with that
if obama is actually running the show
and not biden oh i'm just saying i'm
cool with that oh we do have a little
work to do with you still okay okay
we'll get you you'd rather biden be at
the helm is that where you're no but no
but biden obviously isn't in charge it's
not a question so in essence yes i do
think which gets to your question oh
this is it this is it yeah um
well first i would say that biden
obviously is not in charge i think what
sort of happened in that moment is that
everyone realizes how bad all of this is
we all know inflation supply chain
ukraine afghanistan okay all the stuff
right we all know how bad it is we know
the polls are terrible all of that
everyone also knows that kamala was
polling at zero literally zero in her
own party when she dropped out and then
they chose her quite simply because of
the color of her skin we we see these
are she was a black female
and her genitals yes so
they know that this thing is so damaged
right now
that the other part is that joe biden
has dementia or or something like
dementia he then that is very sad i
don't mean it to be glib or anything
else
i don't think he's going to even make it
between that and now it's coming out
with the hunter biden laptop so i think
the system is now figuring out a way to
push him out the fact that jen saki just
announced this week that she's leaving
to of course go to msnbc so she's the
chief liar paid liar in america and now
she's going to do it just on a tv
channel i think the system is shifting
and it's realizing man biden dementia
all the problems and and what obama did
right there was sort of just assert him
he just pushed himself back in and
obviously he's not going to get a third
term in a traditional sense but they'll
let kamala take over
and she will probably just have to kiss
the obama ring and do exactly what
you're asking for which i think will
lead to an awful lot of bad policies
that are just a continuation of what's
going on yeah okay so put a timeline on
it is are the are the are the looming
midterms the last straw or is that their
is that their flash point or their
well look the thing is their convenient
milestone you always have to remember
the machine does crazy things so
obviously right now everyone thinks it's
going to be the crazy red wave right
everyone that's what every pole is
saying everyone's predicting it you know
what kovid magically comes back in
october and suddenly it's male in
balloting and harvest ballot harvesting
and all the blue states and then
suddenly it's not such a wave and then
they can
you know who knows but that it's a game
it's it's a giant game of thrones chess
game that is that is many layered beyond
just what the republicans voted 5148 on
this thing
so that that's basically who did they
replace him with though i mean so so now
you then it goes to the bench okay so
the bench becomes what pete buddhich
that's the bench he's gay that's good
enough who's good enough i think he's
really smart guy i don't i mean he's
only run a small town in
south bend indiana why is he the
transportation secretary i don't know
nobody knows the same rights
well yeah they said he's he's the
teacher are you trying to say that
you're gonna be the next transportation
secretary is that what you're saying but
i'm as qualified as pete
i can tell you that his confirmation
hearing was something of a joke yeah uh
well were there vehicles in your town uh
yes there were is there a bus service
yes
uh i'm i'm done with my list senator
yeah that's it that's nothing there is
nothing to it how do you process this
because you probably well let me just
say this
i think a very number one you're not far
off dave i don't think i'm not willing
to say that biden has dementia but
clearly he ain't exactly all that are
you is anyone at this table confident
that the president of the united states
is cognitively able to be the president
right now and truly making all of the
decisions
i don't think he's making all decisions
i think it's speculation what he has i
don't know
he did handle you know his speech about
ukraine and like i thought you even said
that he did a decent job with that
um it's the best i've seen him do okay
and that was a month ago so every now
and again he can snort adderall and
basically read a teleprompter i mean
that's basically it you know i like that
um but
let's
let's play a game if pence was the
president
right and he's doing you know mike pence
type things and trump rolls into the
white house you don't think everyone's
just gonna be grabbing on trump and
pence'll be kind of walking around like
a pencil neck i think it's a very
similar like it's a yearning for
something better is really what it is
and obama shows up and everyone's like
holy [ __ ] this is the guy
much like i think that's exactly what
would happen in a if if trump left and
pence was the president but what do you
guys think about the respect level that
moment when he put his hand on his
shoulder you it's not like people can
just walk up to barack obama and touch
him yeah and and biden's right behind
him clearly talking to him
it's not he doesn't have no sensors
right no sensory abilities
sorry obama knew what was happening he
went out of his way to ignore him and
continue
like does that seem crazy to you that
he's making some sort of move no it did
it was clear yeah so think about it this
way say you say you uh we run sales
officers so say i go into one of my
sales guys's office and the guy who runs
that office he's a sales leader say i
spend one hour just
undermining him and talking about how
special i am
what the hell am i doing am i building
leaders so to me that didn't come across
as biden being a trump uh what's his
name obama being a king maker that came
across as obama being a king not a king
maker right he has an opportunity to be
known as a king maker now that's a next
level type of stuff because now you're
in the league of you know reagan who he
helped someone become a king maker bush
senior was made
through
reagan being the king maker lincoln
ulysses s grant two term president king
maker and that didn't come across as a
king man you came in to steal the show
and it wasn't about you obama it's about
the current president and it didn't
happen so that was a that was a hit a
mis opportunity on his end and in
regards to how people view it it doesn't
look strong at all uh obama looked like
he
was semi condescending a little bit like
yeah you know
i got that feeling from him
let me ask you yeah because you're
bringing up your sales leaders and your
offices you travel
it'd be the equivalent it's like i'm
almost going to make an analogy here
you're obama and you roll up to one of
your offices in houston
and they're usually following their
sales leader yeah you know call him jim
but you roll up
jim's the man 364 days a year but pat
shows up
and everyone in the office starts paying
attention to pat i've seen what happens
when you roll up to the office
there's signs welcome pat
there's a little bit of that in that
right yeah but your job is to build that
person yeah your job is to build that
person i totally get it like your job is
to like for example the dylan's coach
right dylan's coach ricky is teaching
him how to do baseball every time he's
teaching them i go stand right there
okay
and i'll tell him i say hey
so you challenge him you push them a
little bit but you seem uncomfortable
tell me why well listen patrick you know
sometimes parents i said i'm not that
parent keep pushing him i want to
empower you he says you have no idea how
important this is you know every single
time after a game he's talking to dylan
because he's got an insurance policy
from me because i empowered him now let
me give you the flip side of the coin is
sometimes
that leader is doing a shitty job which
is here
and sometimes if the leader is doing a
shitty job you come up you're like dude
i don't want my reputation to be tied to
him because obama may have three other
moves that no one knows about on how to
replace him in december and november but
no one knows about that and that
narrative is going to change like this
first of all let me simplify something
for you guys
andrew cuomo went from winning a
flipping emmy and writing the book
getting a 5 million advance and he was
ahead of trump every day would listen to
him in his press conference he would do
six months later boom they dropped him
and he's disappeared when's the last
time he saw andre cuomo what have you
heard about he was a hero he was gonna
beat trump he would have been so much
more presidential this guy would have
been so much more presidential do not be
surprised if they drop biden like a bad
habit in literally seconds boom it's
happening now he disappears and he's
gone do you agree with him dave a
hundred percent yeah a hundred percent
people need to understand what politics
is and you just explained what it is it
is it is game of thrones it is game of
thrones they have used by biden remember
obama did not even support biden
throughout most of the primary remember
that everyone kept saying well why isn't
he supporting his guy because he knew it
was seriously damaged also don't forget
nobody really wanted biden remember at
that moment when
mike bloomberg ran his fake presidential
candidacy for a month and they threw him
on stage twice and it was awful
embarrassingly
embarrassing made 100 million dollars
for that 100 million dollars for and he
obviously didn't want to be president
but they all felt man biden is bad but
they needed to figure out who was it
going to be and was it going to be gay
pete or elizabeth warren who's a
socialist or crazy bernie so they all
coalesced around the guy that was sort
of loosely holding together the old
thing that we kind of remember bloomberg
i remember that vividly yeah you wait
did you say you campaigned for him i
went to one of his events jesus in miami
francis suarez was there i want to say
so
just so you know when we're done with
him yeah you guys got to play basketball
no we'll play basketball but i mean when
we've completely
what's your favorite restaurant what is
like what is the greatest place i could
take you just as the fire as the floor
anywhere anywhere i think you literally
would be rocking this place but yeah
it'd be casa d'angelo okay i've never
been there no but we need to go to a car
in miami we're going to carbon in south
beach no i haven't been yet everyone's
freaking out you moved to miami you've
got to go to carbon every every day
somebody said are you saying you're
taking us to carpenters
when you're when we are done with you
signed sealed delivered registered
republican but that would be no fun dave
we wouldn't have any confidence wait a
minute wait a minute
we can one-up it why don't we take him
to mar-a-lago
we can
and by the way why don't you tell them
what happened when you and your husband
met trump what did he do with melania
that's a that's a good story it's really
an incredible i'll try to do this
somewhat quick version of it we go it
was the week of impeachment the uh there
was 18 impeachment i was like which one
dude yeah the first the first shaman the
original and remember remember remember
those two weeks where everybody everyone
in mainstream media the walls are
closing in trump is freaking out
so mueller's got him the whole thing so
i heard i was at a turning point usa
thing in west palm i i spoke and then
then trump announced that he was coming
so they cleared out all the so basically
i ended up opening for him and then for
trump he spoke yeah dude but it wasn't
planned that way it was just that he
announced that he was coming out of
nowhere so then so i spoke he speaks i
had never heard him speak in person
before and first so already something
had moved with me that morning because
when he spoke and you see him speak live
and then you read the media after you
can really see the disconnect so there's
a beautiful moment in his speech where
he's talking about wind power and he's
like i know wind power more than anybody
and nobody knows more about wind than me
and the turbines and he's going on and
it's so obviously a joke it's so
obviously just a punk and i turned to
david and i said to him i guarantee you
politico is going to write a headline or
one that donald trump says he knows more
about when and of course five minutes
later the headline shows up anyway
uh we see junior there and we become
sort of friendly he says you want to
come to dinner with kimberly and i to
mar-a-lago tonight so obviously we said
yes
we go in again this is the height of
impeachment we're in the you know
there's two rooms there we're in the
smaller rooms there's only about 20
people or so there's trump sitting there
with melania
and rudy giuliani and and one or two
other people
and he has his shirt open really open no
tie you see yeah so first off you never
see trump like this right
his jacket's kind of leaning back he
looks relaxed his hair looked relaxed
like he's just and he's laughing and
having a blast and i'm just you know
we're not sitting at the same table but
i just kind of have my you know i'm just
looking right
anyway at the end of dinner junior says
hey you want to meet my dad so obviously
yeah i'd love to meet your dad so we we
walk over and and uh the president's
sitting and he says dad i want you to
meet dave rubin um and and he looks at
me and he's kind of he's sitting so he
looks up and he's like i kind of
recognize you i kind of and i was like
oh well i'm on tucker a lot or maybe you
see me i'm saying he says oh yeah yeah
that must be it and then he turns to
david my husband and he goes well who
are you
and he goes well i'm his husband and he
goes husband husband
that's great you guys are gay
he goes melania can you believe it these
two guys are gay
he goes
he goes guys let me tell you something
you know what your only problem is
you're too handsome both of you guys are
too handsome yeah that's what he said
and then melania then uh she's kind of
point she's with a friend she's kind of
pointing at david so david walks around
the table to talk to melania and then
it's me junior and trump and then
somebody grabbed junior so now it's just
me and trump and this is also so it's
impeachment and it's also right when
bloomberg got in the race yeah so i had
this moment alone with trump i'm like i
gotta say something that says you know
something so i was like i was like mr
president i just got to tell you my
crazy theory and my theory is
that the machine wants biden because
it's just a vestige of the old thing but
they know he can't survive in the
debates because he's so bad so so
bloomberg is in basically as a decoy
which i really believe is what happened
they threw him in it was never real but
they needed because biden was still
leading they needed all the energy
remember those two debates with
bloomberg it was only about him biden
barely spoke because they knew he would
break down under under attacks
so i tell him this i said it's a
complete decoy bloomberg's not running
it's all about biden and he's he's like
this he's like you know
that's that's something that's something
and then he goes and this also really
changed me on trump he reaches across
the table and he puts his hand on
melania like very gingerly softly puts
his hand on melania and he goes honey
honey listen to this and he said it
lovingly right and the the meme is that
they hate each other or she's a cat you
know kept she slapped whatever that one
time they played it a million times i'm
telling you he did it in the way a
husband that loves his wife would touch
her hand and then he called her honey so
the way he did that so he has me repeat
what i said to him
uh to her
and i say it and she kind of nods and
then he goes nah he just hates me
talking about bloomberg meaning that's
why he got it he just hates me but the
thing that moved me more than the gay
thing or that silly story is that he
loves his wife it was very obvious that
i told him something interesting and his
first inclination
was to tell his wife what does that tell
you about the guy very interesting very
interesting yeah i've
i've heard him a few times at mar-a-lago
and i got to tell you
the guy could have been a comedian yeah
he's a stand-up he's a stand-up
because there's no cameras he gets up
and it's 90 minutes no script no nothing
any
half the time you're laughing with jokes
and obviously he's trolling i think he's
going to go all the time as the greatest
troll of all time i think he has the
gold medal for it i think he owes the
guinness book of world record for it i
don't think anyone's going to come close
to him as a troll he's in the league of
his own but what's so impressive about
the whole the situation is the fact that
he's about to get impeached the second
time biden could potentially win and
he's just having a good time i'm telling
you let's see this guy yeah shirt open
like this
there was something it was just like he
he that also was when i was just like
all of media it broke down a lot of
things for me that he loves his wife he
didn't care about gays that the media is
just so dishonest it wasn't just the
wind power article that i knew was gonna
come it was just he's freaking out you
know he's in his inner sanctum with his
and it was like no he isn't he's sitting
there laughing his ass off
they just lie about it they really they
really don't like this guy too much they
really don't like this guy too much
but here's
going back to it here's the thing
the bench is deep on the right the bench
is not deep on the left even if i ask
you right now who
you couldn't come up with five names on
the left booker not going to happen no
pete
beto who do you got no they'll make it
they'll make it bp that's the one that
they'll move on they'll make it be pete
yeah don't forget about gavin
is going to be there there's no question
it's going to be there gamma's going to
be there no question do you have any
stars you're excited about outside of
mansion because he's not going to run
he's not going to run cinema's not going
to run and you don't think mansion would
run if mansion ran he would never get
the support from the left halsey
gathered would never get the support
from the left so because you need to
rally your base right and who's the
democratic base right now it's a lot of
the aoc crowd the bernie crowd
but that's not who the true democratic
voter is like the the loudest people in
the room the 10 on that side just like
the do you like do you like tulsi i'm
guessing you probably like yeah i mean i
don't follow her well enough to be like
that's my girl yeah uh but yeah i do
like the fact that she challenges the
establishment yeah she's she's a good
woman we've become friendly she's a good
woman
i can't i i mean i say this to her
privately all the time but it's like how
are you a democrat still it just doesn't
make sense
why does she move into florida by the
way i mean well she loves hawaii
yeah oh yeah we go back and forth we're
uh uh her flight is a long flight we're
trying to get a date for her to get on
the podcast the next time she's crazy
idea crazy idea we go to hawaii we go to
hawaii we do the show
hawaii
you guys go to hawaii and you interview
tulsi that'd be great what does she say
when you question her about being a
democrat i don't want to say anything
that we've talked about privately but
you know i i think i can say it's
obvious from her public statements that
she's hanging on by a thread that that
she's trying to hold a position that i
think is an honorable position that
they're not all insane and that there
could be a decent liberal left
i think that's what you're trying to say
you are or at least were
and it just and trust me i'm a guy that
my first book was all it was a defense
of liberalism
it's just it doesn't work anymore trump
you know i kept making the argument and
trust me it was not easy to come out as
a trump supporter or it's just a stupid
statement a trump supporter i was i
voted for trump yes i voted for a guy
who was president um i was making the
argument for a long time that trump
actually was defending liberalism and
conservatism it was obvious how he was
defending conservatism he believed in
the free market he was appointing
conservative judges things like that
obviously but he was defending
liberalism because look the guy
he had a freaking rainbow uh
flag on stage with him before he was
president he was actually defending
equality remember that moment at the
state of the union i'm sure you guys saw
it when he talked about all
uh was it all-time low black and
hispanic unemployment and the entire
congressional black caucus sat there
like this and didn't applaud
he did not care about any of those
things he was actually trying to save
both you're never going to get a more
liberal conservative real that's really
the truth he doesn't care remember his
answer on the trans bathroom thing they
said to him uh what do you think about
trans bathrooms when that was a big
thing he goes i'm a builder if you tell
me i could build a hotel with one
bathroom you know how much i'm gonna
save i would freaking love to do that
that's the right answer that's the right
answer
but they said he's a transphobe and he
hates gays and he hates black people
what is going on with the whole trans
thing these days i don't know if this is
the direction by the way
if there's ever been a time you want to
be your friend you want to do that now
yeah
well no but here's the thing though you
make a very good point if there's ever
been a time to be a trans in palm
springs this is the time to do exactly
here's why here's why here's why because
palm springs woke council votes and
pilot scheme to pay 20 transgender
residents up to 900 a month for two
years in human universal basic income
but even cities mayor thinks it's a
waste of money uh palm springs is to
spend two hundred thousand dollars on a
guaranteed income scheme not only
applies to cities transgender non-binary
resident california city council voted
unanimously on thursday and favored the
pilot scheme which will give 20
residents between 600 to 900 a month for
two years uh the city council christie
uh backed the scheme told the late time
that she felt incredibly proud of the
city for coming in the right side of
history and supporting our trans and
non-binary gender non-conforming
community yes the mayor palm springs
lisa middleton who herself is trans and
transgender she's trans said
she did not think the scheme would
succeed but voted for it anyway so
um
how do you process that dave palm
springs got 47 000 population
i think
46
980 people are going to become trans
within 24.
i've actually got the hormones in my car
if you guys would
this
this [ __ ] could really make you become a
total and cap likes check me out of
society the idea that they when they say
they're going to give money to trans i'm
going to give 900 that means they're
going to take money from someone else a
business owner in palm springs the guy
who owns the pizza shop will have a few
dollars or a few cents less than his
paycheck so they can pay trans people to
do what this has nothing to do with
being bigoted towards trans people i
want them to have the same equality and
dignity obviously i'm so boring having
to say all that stuff all the time you
know it's just like it's just obvious
but what are they saying okay
okay so we're gonna start paying people
with limps you know they got problems
too you know you got a limp you see a
guy walking down the street with olympia
you know pay this guy something i'm
gonna start limping dave you should
start limping you should stop did they
say why they're paying them right that's
the why
but but by the way one very interesting
thing can you pull up boris johnson what
he said yesterday oh god i think you can
say he's going trans did you hear what
boris said yes crazy hair oh by the way
did you hear what foreign
you're going to be blown away what boris
said yesterday okay uh uh
put put biological he said biological
males that's the quote you want to pull
up uh
okay there you go right there second
line make it a little bit closer so the
audience can see it he said this
yesterday
i don't think that biological males
should be competing in female sports and
maybe that's a controversial thing but
it just seems to be sensible so boris
johnson comes out saying
i don't think biological males should be
competing in female sports and maybe
that's a controversial thing but it just
seems sensible doesn't that sound like
common sense like my god a politician
telling the truth boris johnson out of
everybody from uk he seems to be nailing
it these days a lot of the quotes i hear
from him he was not in touch with his
wife but in in regards to the comments
he's making it's pretty so he said i
trust the british people to make their
own decisions that was the famous lineup
of it
i could have done it better i could have
done better if i get another chance for
that biz doc's actually great at accents
do you want to give it an english accent
on the trans thing as a father of two
two girls i mean i felt terrible for all
those girls in the ivy league that were
competing with a guy that had longer
arms in size 13 and a half feet
those are called flippers by the way in
the water you know that's
however i look at title ix and i go wait
a minute wait a minute how many people
like gave their careers pushing for
title ix so we could have this
non-discrimination of budget and
decisions in women's collegiate sports
okay well then if you draw it out title
ix would actually com
support trans competing with trans
so
there
why why is this such an issue and it
just it just shocks me because it's like
somebody wants it to be a wedge issue
nobody wants it to be solved there's
somebody that doesn't want it to be
solved they just want it to be a wedge
issue and that's
that's how i see trends by the way leah
thomas has a penis still by the way no
he's saying yes yeah so it's still
william yeah
yeah now that does
that disappoint you well have you guys
have you guys seen the uh the time lapse
video that they showed on one of the
races when you see it you really realize
how to control the system then you see
what the penis
different video
no you they show you a time lapse of the
race and when you see him her whatever
crushing them you're like man it's just
so obvious how unfair this is but
there's also another incredible video
that you guys gotta gotta see uh from
about six years ago right before
letterman stepped away from the the late
show he has serena williams on and sick
you saw this sick have you seen this
yeah no but you don't go no no you go
ahead it's it's it's it's incredible
because oh what she says about playing
against men yeah she says andy murray
wants to play me yes he would crush me
she says she goes as far to say this is
her words yeah she says men's tennis and
women's tennis are different from sports
yes i saw that and this is the best
female tennis player of all time now
you've got ron desantis doing like a
watered-down version of it and he's
hitler that's where we're at
what is
the lgbt and now it's q-i-e-p-p i've
seen you say a joke lmnop yeah nobody
knows what is it
nobody knows it doesn't matter and you
know on the trans thing look
uh douglas murray you guys may know
douglas murray he's a british
conservative writer really brilliant he
wrote a book called um madness of crowds
and in it he happens to be gay also and
in it he separates the chapter on lgb
from t because these things actually
have nothing to do with each other
because one who you're attracted to is
very different i so for example i have
no more insight into what it is like to
be trans than you do right bingo you're
straight i'm gay okay nobody cares
actually except except for the the
people constantly smashing us with this
but the idea that these letters got put
together is very very dangerous and and
actually i think in many ways it's it's
anti-gay because the gay movement the
people that were that were protesting
stonewall you know 40 years ago and the
entire gay movement was always about
equality harvey milk the everything
always about equality let us have equal
rights make sure that we don't have to
go to underground bars to meet people
and let us get married if i want to be
miserable and married like the rest of
you i i have that right it's an old joke
but it always works thank you um
that's what it was about and the problem
is chris rock has a great line about
this in one of his stand-up specials
from 20 years ago the cops need a
certain amount of crime
and that's basically what the activists
need so the gay's got equality that's
all he ever wanted you're equal do
whatever the hell you want you're an
equal member of society black people you
are equal there are no laws punishing
you women you can vote you are equal no
we we did it in america and now i think
we did this about an hour ago but we're
just unearthing all of the [ __ ] musk
musk taking over we're going to hammer
before we take some call-ins musk taking
over twitter and you know wapo coming
out and saying uh you know how this is
bad for freedom of speech and they're
saying what they're saying with their
message and then i texted the
set villain this morning babylon b i
said look i saw your commentary what you
said the fact that musk called them up
and said hey
you know are you sure you guys are being
silenced and yes we are and says okay so
let me see and then he said i may have
to consider buying twitter and but he
can't comment on it i was going to have
him call in today big fan of yours as
well but he's a great dude yeah really
good dude but so with what's going on
today with what's going on with musk not
taking over twitter and what he's doing
what are the chances you think of a
babylon b being back on or a trump being
back on or some of these guys being back
onto twitter what do you think well let
me add one other i mean you know the
tucker carlson has been suspended for
the last three weeks basically because
he basically repeated the babylon bee
line he just said something in effect
that there are differences between men
and women so the largest
most viewed cable news host in the
history of television has not been on
twitter in the last two weeks three
weeks and nobody's even talking about
that so what are the chances i would say
they just upped they just up pretty
significantly probably
probably 50 percent because elon is not
stupid right so he's obviously not
stupid he's basically the the greatest
industrialist and genius and
technologist that we have
he knew that by doing this it was gonna
open up that door for all of those
questions what the real the real one is
about trump right because that's where
this all leads you can throw babylon
back on there you get tucker back on
there uh you can put roger stone or
whoever else sitting member of congress
margery taylor green is not on there you
can put all those people but it all
comes down to trump so elon did
something here with that in mind and i
don't know what the answer to that is
let me tell you if he does come back on
if trump does come back on
there's going to be
uh
a lot of people that'll be upset who
started their own social media companies
who were relying on that including
himself because it's truth network
remember that smack that was a four or
five billion dollar
you know and yeah you had a conversation
yeah exactly and so there's a lot of
guys that uh uh you know are complaining
about truth network having a lot of
issues and challenges i can't get on i
can't do this i can't do that as i'm
calm but if trump comes back on where's
the argument so
twitter bringing trump back on may help
the valuation of twitter so the
investors may sit there and say we can't
say we support this decision publicly
but privately in our bank account we
support this decision you know good move
right there musk for helping us make
another example but think about this
think about how more complex it is than
that because okay so let's say they put
trump back on well apple won't let truth
in the app store right now so that
because it's about trump so
yes
so now you have a much bigger problem
because the real gatekeeper is the app
store not not one platform
and then the other piece of this is
remember remember how they coordinate so
when trump got kicked off all of those
things it all happened within about six
hours it was like he's off pinterest and
spotify he can't listen to music and he
can't put recipes up anymore and all
those things and i i want to i i think i
asked him on my show so he won't who
would never problem repeating this i
asked teal about this like how do these
guys make their decisions how is it
possible that everyone makes the exact
same decision at the ex and basically
his argument is that they're all just
cowards like they just someone makes a
decision then everyone else is like okay
let's just make a decision so if if elon
does it and now they let twitter back on
now apple now it's on tim cook tim cook
has to make a decision right do we let
them do we have to remove twitter now
from the app store and then then that
goes then to facebook and instagram and
everyone else so this is but elon knew
what he was doing he's not stupid right
so something is really he joked about
buying facebook yesterday but facebook
is way too big it's not the same size as
uh as twitter but his next move of
picking up cnn if he buy cnn and twitter
it's going to be a whole different story
by the way do we have some callers or no
yeah john's got something he's got some
callers okay john uh tell us who you
have some callers who got questions
specifically for our guest dave rubin
yes we have phillip on the line phillip
how you doing
hi good morning everybody my name is
phillip richter from the cayman islands
how's everyone doing today fantastic i
love the cayman islands so tell us
what's on your mind
what's on my mind in your opinion what
is the best way to have conversations on
polarizing topics in my experience
everyone likes to cut you off
mid-sentence and say you're wrong and
use some facts they heard on twitter but
in my opinion that just furthers the
divide at a time when we need to come
together so i'd like to hear your
thoughts i mean it's partly you do this
what we can do you do what we're doing
right now you know it's like obviously i
know i know a certain amount you about
you guys you know a certain about about
me and then you kind of do the dance and
you figure out some things and we'll do
it again and i'll have you guys on my
show and we'll chat about all this stuff
i think having doing it over a drink
helps
doing it doing it tequila for me what's
your drinking choice you seem like a
scotch i'm an old-fashioned guy you're
not yeah yeah i saw it okay um
i think that helps you know not doing it
on social media is really the answer
we're it made us less social we thought
it was going to make us more social
we're 20 years in it made us more
neurotic and crazy and all of that stuff
trying to actually sit with someone and
give them the benefit of the doubt but i
get it it's hard the question's right
it's like they end up yelling at you
just be a little bit better than the guy
sitting across from you and if you do
that then maybe he tries to do it next
thing you know you've you know you
really scaled this thing up here's what
i would do philip i'll give you my
feedback so
i came up when i first uh started paying
attention to politics and started
questioning things
um i did a show with the krla back in
the days called saving america this is
in 2009-2010
in glendale it was i was uh my studio
was there then it was prager was here uh
hugh hewitt
uh peg beck everybody was on krla back
in the days
and uh one day becca does an
announcement endorsement for us and we
do this video i showed this at this
event in burbank hotel and next thing
you know i'm thinking this
announcement's going to be big because
back then beck was big and you know fox
not that he's not big today but he was
like he was
he was tucker before tucker it was back
right
and uh he had this thing he talked about
the four e's education entrepreneurship
enlightenment all these things he talked
about
so i make the announcement my san
francisco office comes up to me straight
they're both straight but they came up
to me
uh we're gonna have to leave why is that
because
we don't align ourselves with back in
our office we have to shut it down
i lost that entire office in northern
california when they came up to me
so i lost another office i'm like okay
interesting
uh i don't know this was going to take
place but fine let me go see another
step i'm going to take so what i started
doing philip that you're asking this
question is
rather than making statements until it's
worldly known who you are or your
community knows who you are
ask questions hey this site says this
that site says this what do you think
about this
hey i noticed the other day tucker said
this but i noticed maddow said this who
do you agree they both didn't make a lot
of sense to me hey i saw my mom say this
my dad says this what do you think about
it then let people debate and have their
own discourse and generally when we talk
out loud and we're having a debate we
will generally common sense will lead to
a conclusion and then from there you
know you got what you got going on there
but they'll make up their minds for
themselves don't come across like i've i
never liked when people would come
across them well let me tell you jesus
did you it's not my style my style was
listen let me tell you i was skeptical
here's what i was i went to church don't
you come and find out for yourself see
if it works out for you that approach is
more okay i'm willing to rather than
forcing stuff down people's throats
let's see if we can get two more callers
in if we got another one john do you
have another one ready outside of philip
yes daryl daryl how are you daryl
hey can you hear me i can't what are you
based out of
i am based out of pa
fantastic what part
uh like lehigh valley okay
i'm a democrat my question is how would
he define
uh the principles of the modern right
because it seems like increasingly in
this country it's just basically
the left versus the anti-left and
there's no really foundational like
ideology or anything
of people who are just anti-left it
seems like they're libertarian one day
and then they're on tucker the next day
so what exactly would he define the
principles of
uh the modern right to be it's a great
question it's actually very much what my
book is about and it's in certain ways
what i'm really devoting my life to now
what i talked about earlier about okay
you've got the sort of disaffected
liberals you've got the libertarians
you've got these religious conservatives
how can you bring all these people
together so he's asking about like what
are the foundational ideas very simply
individual rights number one individual
rights everyone that is here legally is
treated absolutely the same under the
law
and then from individual rights then you
can sort of extrapolate that up where
states rights matter more than the
federal government that everything
should be as local as possible the
government should basically be out of
your way and you have to make some
decisions for yourself and then on the
social stuff where say
some people on the right don't agree
with me i'm not gonna force them to do
anything they're entitled to their
religious liberty and they can't force
me to do anything and if we can
basically just i mean the real answer is
just go back to the founding documents
that's it go back to the founding
documents it's all there they did it
they were a lot better than all of us
and they did it it's there and if we
turn back to that we'll be all right
darryl are you still on john do we still
have daryl on or no i'm curious
no he's gone oh can we can daryl if
you're listening can you call back in
can you call back in because i got a
question for you uh john when sometime
we get a caller let's keep them on in
case there's a follow-up we can't keep
them muted but uh if if daryl you're
you're you're uh if you're able to call
back on i got a question for you here's
my question he's on now okay daryl can
you hear me daryl's back sure daryl what
do you do for a living what business are
you in i'm in tech you're in tech what
part of texas are you an engineer
yourself what do you do
uh i work in like i.t i'm an analyst
okay what school did you go to
penn state penn state okay uh and when
you were in high school who were you in
high school
like who what like what did you were you
the geek were you the athlete were you
the cool guy were you part of chess club
were you okay what sport did you play
i was a runner
uh uh so
so uh coming up as a kid growing up at
what point did you know which side you
were on politically what like if you
were said i was 15 years old i had a
conversation with my dad i had a
conversation with my teacher what was
that defining moment where you kind of
are like i think i'm a democrat i think
i'm a republican
yeah i would say my uh ap u.s history
class and you know just discussing
things and um you know i
that was around the time obama was
running for his second term so i was i
was uh you know definitely trying to
weigh the issues but
okay can you tell me about your ap us
history class uh professor tell me uh
what this professor you know what who he
or she was like
yeah she was i would say she was a
moderate because she would show um a
little some clips of people
um like you know
on fox news but she would also show like
clips of the west wing so we kind of got
an even balance so what do you think
would have happened if that professor of
yours was a guy named thomas sol
i think i actually think it would been i
think i probably would have been more to
the right but i'm someone who looks sad
because i know who thomas is but i but i
look at kind of both sides so whatever
someone says i kind of try to find the
opposite have you ever voted for
somebody on the right
i have voted for someone on the right
although they're not considered on the
right anymore but would it be a
president or was it like more of a
senator or congress or mayor or
something else it was a presidential
primary it was a presidential primary
okay got it so they wouldn't be
considered someone on the right today
i'm curious who that person was someone
that went left so good john kasich
okay okay perfect okay so i can see that
i remember john kasich at one point he
had some momentum okay but they banished
him yeah i fully get it so so tell me
why you're a democrat today i'm curious
sure i think that democrats are i think
in the democratic party there's more
room for debate like in my opinion um
you know there are plenty of left-wing
people that i
listen to like
you know secular talk and people like
that and it feels like you can critique
democratic presidents versus the right
it feels like if you say anything about
trump then you don't really have an
audience on the right anything negative
okay let's unpack that let's unpack that
so tell me why you think the
democrats are more open-minded and
tolerant than those on the right
tell me why like give me examples of
like give me an example of rachel maddow
inviting trump over or rachel inviting
descendants i think i think the i think
really when you because i don't really
like corporate media i think they're all
like hacks i think cnn and msnbc are
then tanked for democrats and fox is
just a republican but i'm saying even i
watched a lot of independent media and
i've noticed that a lot of independent
media on the left is able to say like i
didn't like obama's drone strikes or i
didn't like this versus it seems like
the right
independent media
i wouldn't consider you obviously right
but i'm talking about political media
is more like okay fox news is not
supporting trump enough and trump trump
trump i mean if you look at people like
you know shapiro and bongino and
you know
people like that in hannity they
basically just support whatever trump
does versus i felt that the left-wing
media is able to criticize
uh both democrats and republicans okay
fair enough so darryl what would you say
is a woman
what would i say is a woman what's a
woman
a woman is defined by the um gametes so
if she has eggs she's a woman if if
if there is you know sperm present then
it's a man
how how can how how is it that to me
what you just said is very logical right
we learned this in ninth grade or tenth
grade when we took biology or life
science right
how is it that the left has a hard time
saying the democrats has a hard time
repeating what you just said after a
basic question was asked of somebody of
what is a woman that that is about to be
a supreme court justice and want to ask
what a woman is she couldn't answer that
and the democrat the media that you're
talking about they defended her saying
she's got a good point
well i think i think there are two
different things i think she's qualified
more than other people in terms of her
that's her question that's not that
question though that's not quite i
actually don't agree with democrats on
that um okay you know i think the truth
i think the tricky thing is that um even
democrats who you know
think think like i do they want to be
supportive of of the
trans community
they want to be supportive of the trans
community okay so even people will agree
with what i say so so then so then this
this is the disconnect for me this is
where i have a challenge with it this is
where i they lose me okay
i i'm lost the moment you have to
blindly support anything that's on the
left and you no longer say that just
doesn't make any sense what are we
talking about do you know the first time
where we've all had the conversation of
what a woman is was four weeks ago do
you know the first time where we've
questioned that question was four weeks
ago
how how is that even a topic where no no
no no no
she's got a point and she's just this is
not i'm not a doctor i'm not a biology
doctor and i can't even answer that
question so for me when you say
open-minded or for me when you say
tolerant
i don't know if you will see the folks
on on the other side on the side that
you're representing yourself
seem the last especially five years
maybe the last eight years they don't
seem too tolerant i'm a guy that came
from a uh democratic background my
mother is a communist my dad was an
imperialist but i grew up being a
democrat i'm a clinton guy i grew up i'm
like okay these guys are for everybody
these guys are for helping everybody
else out do you know exxon had the most
profitable
uh quarter they've ever had in the
history of exxon why
based on policies that seem like it's
going to help the left and it's going to
help the middle and low-income families
but it only helps the rich do you know
all this printing of money to give more
money to low and middle income families
who would ended up helping the most the
rich got richer and the poor got poorer
do you know all these policies that seem
like they're so noble they're so
honorable let's help these people out
they keep hurting the people that need
it the most do you know the whole thing
with cops let's defund the police that
was a campaign that went viral on that
side political side that went viral do
you know who is begging for more cops
people who live in low-income families
people who live in middle income
families
higher class upper class families are
not asking for more cops they're going
to be totally fine so for me
as much as i want to sit there and you
you seem like a very educated guy you
seem like a guy that you went to school
penn state you had a professor that
helped that you had all that stuff that
happened to you but it just seems like
sometimes these arguments that you
listen to eventually common sense wins
and for someone like you go ahead
yeah well i mean yeah i mean and i even
think with the police that's a
complicated issue because you can want
more police and i don't want to get
super political but
um and i think people want more police
but people want police to be prosecuted
and my issue even with the right on the
police is the right
basically took a
police or never be questioned and then
what they and then when they started
rounding up people in canada then all of
a sudden it was like oh my god i can't
believe these police are enforcing these
laws and it's like how are you only
critical of the police when it's
affecting people like you like if you
supported the truck or convoy yeah um
and them pushing back against the
government then you then you should have
been there two years ago when people
were pushing
back against the government so did you
want to say so
but but let me kind of put it back on
you i agree but i also agree bad
teachers should be fired and they
shouldn't have tenure i also agree bad
teachers should be fired and great
teachers need to get a big raise
i also believe it's un it's not fair
that teachers have this card they can
use that they can't be fired it can't be
touched so so this can continue and that
can be the same conversation a bad cop
should be fired bad cops should be going
to jail bad cops should be you know if
they're using that as a power to get
money so don't but what you just said
right there that's not a right thing
that's not a right thing that hey
meaning that's a republican thing or a
democratic thing that's just that city
and that doesn't apply to every single
city and every single community we're
talking about but a guy like you is it
fair to say that you make six figures
plus that you do pretty okay for
yourself um i make i would say i make uh
high five figures i don't make six
speakers close but you're doing good for
yourself you're gonna get there daryl
but you don't get out of yourself i'll
get that okay well daryl first of all i
appreciate you for
being able to have this exchange in the
conversation by the way is this the
first time listening to the podcast or
you've listened to the part no i
actually listened and dave's not gonna
like this i listened for uh i mean i
like some of what will whit says in
terms of some of the christian stuff but
i also listened last week for uh jank uh
because david
he critical i like these guys
can i ask daryl one quick question i
know we gotta go hey daryl how old are
you again
i'm 26. okay cool
um
and you're saying that you're a democrat
do you are most of your friends just
like you or is it more of a diversity of
opinion amongst your friends uh most of
my friends are democrats or they're that
weird space where they're like kind of
like i guess like roganites where
they're kind of like okay a political
but like not mega people so a lot of
people
are my friends kind of like the channel
because i got to get him just like
journal types just like dave said about
having conversations
why don't you have like a a weekly
monthly whatever meeting with your
friends and have those open discussions
and debates and check back with us a
month and see if there's any common uh
answers and not only that record it and
put it on a podcast or youtube because
daryl i got to tell you i've enjoyed my
conversation with you i've enjoyed my
conversation with you and i appreciate
you getting on to listen to both sides
if you listen to wilwood and chank
appreciate you for coming on but daryl i
got one big recommendation for you you
ready for this one sure whatever you do
go buy this book called don't burn this
country that's coming out next week and
folks if you listen to everything we
talked about and you liked it if you
said man this was great you got to go
buy this book we're going to put the
link below put in the comment section as
well as in the chat box section so they
can find it be one the first to order
this book uh and uh dave i gotta tell
you man i've really enjoyed it i'm
looking forward to seeing you guys play
basketball i'll come in cheerleading
and i'm looking forward to that dinner
will happen daryl thanks for the calling
buddy can i just say i'm not blowing
smoke up any earbuds this was seriously
like the most two hours of enjoyment
that i've had in a long time i do a lot
of these obviously you guys all do a lot
of these you have something so good here
what you just did for those last five
minutes like that's your opus right
there that that is your thing you just
did that so well effectively and you
answered your own question from two
hours ago about how do we do this thing
that's it man i appreciate that thank
you thank you thank you thank you
brother once again appreciate you for
coming out this was fantastic uh this
afternoon we have andrew yang coming to
the office four o'clock four o'clock and
then tomorrow we got joe jorgensen 9 a.m
that's going to be here 9 00 a.m uh we
will see you there i know it's not the
typical time at nine o'clock but we'll
see you there and dave uh uh great
having you on take everybody bye-bye bye
bye
you